Henry rollins was on the podcast before
three,
two,
one.
You have very specific style of wearing
the headphones with like one to the side
and Henry rollins does the same thing
and I said,
Oh,
you're wearing your headphones.
Headphones.
Jim Norton style.
I didn't know that you guys had had some
sort of an altercation.
Well how would you this recently,
like a couple months ago,
two months ago,
he didn't say anything.
Someone else told me online.
Oh,
I thought it had.
They're still mad about it.
I'm like,
no.
It was minor.
It was it a minor cold fucking online
people.
They blow everything out of proportion.
We've talked since then.
I like him a lot.
We've interviewed him.
I think he's great.
It's interesting guy.
Very interesting.
We were talking comedy one time and I
forget what he was talking about with
Richard Pryor on the phone,
but he was a little like,
oh,
you don't remember.
Oh,
that's right.
I remember this.
I vaguely remember it.
Yeah,
he was trying to pretend that you didn't
know Richard Pryor and you're like maybe
one of the biggest Richard Pryor fans of
all time.
Yeah,
I love him and it was a silly thing to
try to,
like for what?
Like there's no valor in knowing Richard
Pryor on fire,
on purpose.
There's a weird thing that people do
when they pretend that knowing things
makes them better than you because you
don't know things.
Yeah.
It's very strange.
Like knowing something is just like,
oh,
you know about it,
it's all it is.
And we also get caught up in where Colin
has a brilliant joke about how people,
if you learn something from a movie,
people are embarrassed to go.
I learned that from TV or I learned it
from a movie.
So they try to act like they read it and
he's smarter because you're reading
hated him.
You for that great point.
But you do people feel smarter if they
read something.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's true.
My daughter was just telling me that
today that she,
uh,
she learned something from an animated
movie and uh,
and she said fest,
the weirdest way to learn things ever.
And I'm like,
well,
it's really not.
I go,
it's just,
it's just a thing,
you know,
it's like you can learn things from
anything.
It won't be any different learning from
there.
And then if you hear somebody say it,
but there's just ways that we think are
smart.
Like I just so much smarter if I read
something and,
and just hearing it on the TV,
I like,
I'm a fucking dope repeating what I
heard again.
Well I have a friend who will get upset
if people say they read a book,
if they actually listened to the audio
book.
Really?
Yeah.
It was like,
well did you read it or did you listen
to the audio book?
I'm like,
fuck man.
Like leave the guy alone.
I think listening to it's better.
Well,
it's a,
it's way more productive.
Like you can get it done while you're
doing stuff like driving your car at the
gym or whatever.
Can you see my focus has gotten so
fucked up,
like can you sit down and actually just.
I read a book and then all of a sudden
I'm like,
I doing totally addictive.
I can't fucking read a book anymore that
I can get.
My focus is not there.
I read at night before I go to bed.
That's what I like to do.
I like to read and when,
when I start like having a hard time
paying attention,
that's when it's time to crash.
How long can you read for like a couple
hours.
Oh yeah,
I'm good for a couple hours.
I'm usually good for no more than say
like,
well if I sat down during the day I
could read for about three hours,
but at night,
at night I'm good for about two.
You have that kind of focus?
It depends on what I'm reading.
If it's really interesting you,
I'm to do it.
Well,
I'm reading now.
It's kind of research.
It's about a book called American
Serengeti.
It's about,
uh,
what the,
wildlife used to be on the American
planes like before in the Pleistocene
era,
I guess.
Uh,
you know,
before the Ice Age,
it's pretty crazy shit.
I understood none of those words except
for like the American you said,
the first part I got and the rest of it
I've never heard of.
Well,
there's this guy that I'm having on the
potty.
He was supposed to be here last month.
We had rescheduled to next month,
but he's a wildlife historian or a
biological is and I guess it would be.
I'm not sure which one he would be,
but his name is Dan Flores,
and he wrote this amazing book about
coyotes,
but the history of the coyote,
and he wrote another book about the
history of extinct wildlife in the
American southwest or the American West,
and at one point in time we had all
sorts of crazy shit.
We had cheetahs.
There was cheetahs,
there was lions that were bigger than
African lions.
There was a thing called a short face
bear,
which is fucking enormous bear.
Bigger than a polar bear.
We had.
There's a reason why like,
have you ever seen an antelope like
American antelope,
like a pronghorn antelope.
You know what those are?
I've seen antelope,
but that's the only system.
I said that's an antelope line.
While they're this weird animal that
lives in Colorado and Wyoming and New
Mexico and a lot of different places,
it's a strange animal because it runs
way faster than anything.
They can kill it.
That's it right there and the reason
being is because this animal evolved way
way back hundreds of thousands of years
ago when there were cheated here and
they were really fast things that would
chase it.
Like those fucking things are lightning
fast.
Can out run a cheetah.
Well they can do their best they can to
get you to work.
Yeah,
but whereas like a deer has no shot like
a white tail deer is.
If a child is going after white tail
deer,
cheetahs going to get it.
Did you see the video and have a.
I'm such a fruit.
Like I go online.
I like to watch happy animal videos like
baby elephants cuddling.
I went on a fucking baby elephant,
like youtube loop,
just watching people cuddling with baby
elephants.
They're awesome.
I hold a pencil.
Amazing.
They're really fucking smart man.
They're really,
really just really smart.
But they can remember individual
elephants from like decades ago,
like they can be separated from their
family and not see their family for 20
years and then they reintroduce him and
when you see the two of them to get
together again,
it's fucking heartbreaking because you
like what makes you think about like the
elephants that are in zoos and the
officers who were in the circus you
don't like.
Whoa.
Like what are these things like?
They're not,
they're not,
they're not stupid.
There's something wrong.
Yeah.
There's some animals that are like dear
beautiful and everything like that.
But they have a very limited cognitive
cognitive function.
Their brain doesn't work that good.
It's just real simple because anything
you want to eat me?
No.
Where's the grass?
Let me get the grass.
Anything looking at me?
No.
Whereas the grant one of two thoughts
and then the time to fuck once a year,
it's time to fuck.
Which is crazy.
Which is why they have antlers to fight
off all the other men and fuck.
And then the antlers fall off and then
they're back to normal shit.
But
people think we're unique getting like
Porsche's and Lamborghini.
It's the same thing.
Let's just fucking nicer antlers.
Yeah.
Well they have weapons.
Really.
They fight each other to death.
They kill each other all the time.
They do.
Yeah.
That's fucked.
That's what those things are for those
giant antlers differ stabbing.
They just slam into each other.
They had buddy each other and they
occasionally catch one,
slip it and they broadside and go right
to the fucking lungs.
But a lot of times they'll just kinda
back off like,
all right,
he's got bigger antlers and he smashed
me a little bit and I'll,
I'll fucking.
It's fun to watch one atom of male
animal baclofen another.
It's so much like human beings.
A lot of times it's just posturing.
I'm just going to show you.
That could rip your head off.
All right.
You'll beat it like hippos.
Bite each other a little bit.
And then one's like,
all right,
fuck it leaves.
I was elk hunting once I saw these two l
duke it out.
These two huge animals.
There were about a thousand pounds in
there,
slamming heads into each other,
which is running towards these other
bang and headbutting and smashing
antlers together and they were so big.
I mean these are like enormous elk.
Both of them were around somewhere
around a thousand pounds and just the
force that they generate with their
heads colliding with these antlers.
All of it.
Just for Pussy.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's why I don't think people are so
bad to do what we do because it really
is an animal that were chimps and we're
one step beyond and we just don't do it
that way anymore,
but it's always us fighting to fucking
to mate.
Yeah.
We get laid.
We do with gold lamborghinis.
Fucking beautiful watches and shit.
Yeah.
Or even shows a strength is guys that do
it,
you know,
just brutal guys were big and can fuck
you up.
And they get hot girls.
Sure.
And then just people at the gym just
wearing little clothes.
Flexing.
Yeah,
picking up weights.
It's humiliating.
It's weird.
It's like we have a weird sort of a
connection to these ancient animals that
needed to do that in order to make sure
that the women were attracted to the
strong genes to stay alive.
It's not,
not nearly as important anymore.
It's weird in the gym too,
because I dressed like shit.
Like I obviously,
I mean I can't wear a tank top and would
look silly,
so I wear like sweatpants and like an
old rotten hoodie.
I really look like a bum in the gym can.
I know that I can't compete,
so I'm almost going totally the opposite
way.
Like people wonder like what kind of
shape I might be in.
I know I can't compete on a level of
looking good in a gym.
Like I'm never going to get laid in a
gym.
We'll never know.
Never picked up a girl in the gym.
Well,
I dated a person who trained me.
I didn't want to,
but she knew me.
It was a personality thing.
It was never like a.
It was never like,
wow,
this guy is cute.
I'm going to fuck him.
Like it's never worked that way.
Damn.
No,
never,
never.
I,
I just kinda wanted it.
I'd become friends with them and then
all of a sudden we're fucking like a
year later and like,
well,
how'd that happen?
Just sneak your way in.
I really do.
I just put personality my way into it.
Uh,
and the one girl who I,
I really,
she's still a really good friend of
mine.
We dated for maybe two months and I
think she's in a different place in life
and kind of wanted kids and I'm a
fucking Perv I,
I just can't do it.
And I know that,
but I was so attracted to her.
I was so few.
I wrote a bit about her and one of my in
back and please be offended.
I did a bit about following a girl up
the steps and looking at her badge in
the back of her pants because it was so
nice.
And uh,
tell it was about her.
I did,
I told her after we had dated and she
loved it.
She thought it was really fun and he
said,
Oh my God,
that's the greatest.
She was really a fun person.
But uh,
yeah,
I lost it her for so long and then we
wound up dating,
but I knew her for like a year before we
dated.
When you lust for someone for that long,
finally when you finally get there,
it's such a nerve wracking experience.
Like trying to hold back the Jews.
Ooh.
Ooh,
Well you can't believe it's happening
to.
Yeah,
right.
Like finally I like to come fast though.
I do because sometimes I'll lose my rod
so if I come fast I won.
Then I can compliment them.
See because of the experience.
Like if you lose your heart on your like
ah,
sorry,
this state or whatever,
Shit,
I'm fucked up.
But if you come quick it's like wow,
you did great.
I'm a mess.
It's hard for me to let someone else
make me feel good.
Like it's really hard to just let
someone pleasure me.
I can't do it.
Really?
Yeah.
I admire people who can like I just,
I'm so solo with that stuff.
Wow.
Very different role.
What do you think that's from?
Just compulsion and jacking off and just
being just jacking off so much know
like,
let me hit care of that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Don't bother with that.
Exactly.
I'll throw it,
I'll throw it out that way.
You know,
like when someone's trying to help you
fix something,
you know,
like I got it.
It's Kinda like that.
But with her it was fun.
We just,
we didn't date long too long.
I just,
you know,
I don't like to waste people's time and
I know that I'm not in baby having mode
maybe soon.
You know,
I wouldn't mind if I like something,
but I think so I kind of want a
relationship.
I've been saying that for like the last
few months,
10 years I've been saying that since I
was middling
I,
I want somebody now like because it's
boring by myself.
Thought about sex,
getting laid.
Is it fairly easy if you have money or
you have some kind of personality you
can get laid.
So you kind of want someone like to get
on a plane with or to watch TV with.
That's the shit you missed.
Somebody whose opinion you like someone
to hang out with?
Yeah.
A friend.
That's where it gets weird.
Right.
But you want sexual too though.
My openers were typically women and I
hang out with them and I've never fucked
any of them.
It's never even been an option.
Like,
you know,
Kelsey Cook was my lead and she was just
a friend and we would watch tv like an
old,
like an old couple but just.
But a nonphysical.
It's just took an old.
I'm like an old queen with my fucking
lady friend and I.
So I want that like a friend that I hang
out with,
but someone who I'm also,
you know,
I don't want to date a comedian,
I don't think because it's just,
you know.
Yeah.
I,
I would say that too.
I would say it's just the odds of it
working are so small.
I mean it could work like Tom Seger and
Christina possessed schemes.
Right.
It works and they're both really funny.
Usually one of them is not funny.
It's like usually the woman's funding,
the guy sucks or the opposite and then
they sort of glom off each other.
So when one gets resentful of the other
career goal,
yeah,
that's,
that's the case.
Often that's the case.
Often there's always like one
breakthrough,
one has something going on and the other
one gets bitter,
right?
And they feel bad getting better and
then the other one who presents them
like we're supposed to be partners.
That's a.
that's a hard.
Yeah,
that fuck that.
I couldn't do it.
The only way I could do it is if it was
just like.
I guess it would have to be one of those
things like you were talking about with
your friend where you were friends with
them for a long time,
but you're friends with her for a year
and then you were both looking for
somebody.
You're like,
Hey,
you know what?
I'm fucking this.
This actually kind of works.
We know each other really well.
Like once.
See that's the one of the things about
getting intimate with someone.
Sometimes people get intimate with
people.
You barely know them and sometimes it
works out great,
but sometimes you're just opening up a
fucking bag of worms.
Oh yeah.
Then you realize,
oh,
you're crazy and you want to blame me
for your entire fucked up life.
You know what I realized?
They're crazy when they're fucking
sitting in my house with a suitcase
because I've flown them in.
Maybe I should get to know them first.
I've put a lot of people on planes
before and luggage and I'm like,
no,
fuck them.
But it's like I probably shouldn't know
that they're not unstable first.
Crazy.
Completely crazy.
And then you're in your house and you're
sleeping and they're hovering over you.
Frightened.
Go thinking about putting that pillow
over your face.
I've had a couple of you down.
I've had a couple where I just,
I literally,
I'm not kidding.
I couldn't sleep because it was just
like I could.
I didn't know the person well enough and
like I didn't want to have sex because
that just takes it to another level,
but I mean that's,
that's the price you pay when you're,
you pervert or what?
Just promiscuous.
Just taking a chance.
It's funny in this,
uh,
I stopped saying,
I still say it out of the day,
but I thought to myself,
am I a pervert?
Like I always think perversely,
I'm like not kind,
Kinda like victims.
Like I don't like uh,
I don't like,
like drunk chicks.
I like at one point in my career I did,
but I remember I was on the road and I,
I this girl massage me and she was so
fucking sexy and she stuck her hand in
my mouth,
which I never thought I would like I'd
never had anybody just talk her hand in
her mouth.
She was a little dominant.
Then the first time she massaged me I
was naked and she like pushed my dick
out of the way.
Like it was a disgusting item and it was
so hot that she did that.
But we didn't hook up.
She just moved by Dick
and I told you that was one of the
sexiest thing and I didn't see her for a
year.
And then we,
Mr again,
she understood that like dominance and I
kinda liked her feet a little bit but
there was nothing inappropriate,
happy,
Kinda liked her feet.
Yeah,
she was barefoot and I was just trying
to check it out.
And so it was subtly dominant but she
wasn't jerking me off or anything.
And then she stuck her hand in my mouth.
It was out of my mouth.
That's where it started.
The hand in the mouth was like the first
thing.
Yeah.
But that was after the Dick thing a
while ago,
but she just read me like,
you know,
people couldn't read you like a real,
a woman that you liked can fucking read
you.
And they just get it and it's intuitive
and you don't have to go do this.
They just kind of do it.
It's so weird.
That's a weird thing to do though.
Never ever occurred to me.
You never saw it never occurred to you.
But once she did it,
you thought it was really hot because
her,
her hands were clean little massage oil.
But I mean she was just like.
I always wondered,
I honestly don't remember,
it might've been coco coconut or
might've been a scentless.
It was,
it was more of the,
uh,
like the dis,
the partying.
I think I just kind of kissed her finger
and she just stuck her hand and um,
anyway,
I wound up hanging out with her.
She came to one of my shows and she came
with a friend on the early show and then
she came back on the late show at the
end by herself and she came to my hotel
and she was so drunk and we were fooling
around and I didn't realize how drunk
she was.
I went down on her for a second.
I'm like,
she's fucked up.
Like,
you know how you realize that this is
not,
I don't want to be a part of this.
So I'm like,
I don't have sex with her.
It's just too fucked up.
And she wanted me to fuck her in the
ass.
She put her ass up in the air so he
fucked me in the ass.
Wow.
And when someone is that drunk,
it's hard to go like you're too fucked
up because you were sober 100 percent.
Yeah,
that's right.
You don't drink at all and it'll happen
since you were like 19,
right?
Yeah,
I quit when I was young,
so it's a to me and it never turned me
onto to get someone who's sloppy,
like I don't know what you really want
to do and it's just,
I'm not going to chance you coming out
of it and feeling like I did something
wrong.
Fuck that.
And plus she was loaded and she had,
she had actually driven to the hotel.
So I,
you know,
she,
she was a.
I'm like,
look,
let's just hang out and thank God she
got sick.
Like I was the only time I've ever been
happy to have a girl fucking puke
because she's like,
I'm so fucked up.
I'm like,
oh,
it's okay.
And she's apologizing because he pooky.
I'm like,
it's okay.
And she let me call her and over she let
me get her on the sheet.
I had to talk about her taking her car,
but she let me get her an uber home and
uh,
that worked out okay.
But that should get back to her after
that.
No,
that was the last time I was in town.
We still talked after that.
Um,
but I'm so happy I didn't fuck her
because I wouldn't have felt.
I never felt I don't feel good about.
I don't like somebody who it means too
much to them either.
Like somebody who's like looking at you
like,
oh,
I care for you.
Like if I don't care.
Man.
Was that the case with her?
No,
no,
no.
She was just too drunk.
But I've had that where I think that
sometimes like,
you know how guys will lie to fuck women
will say like,
yeah,
I love you when we don't.
They'll lie and they'll go,
I just want sex.
But they really want love after it.
And if I sense that someone is doing
that,
I still feel like I'm a liar.
If I pretend I don't know what she's
doing so I won't do it.
Yeah.
You're a sensitive guy.
You're trying to avoid the bad feels.
Yeah.
I just don't want to be a creep.
Like it's not even.
I don't even think I'm doing anything
good.
It's like,
yeah,
you're not supposed to fuck someone
who's so drunk that she's going to
vomit.
Like,
you know what I mean?
Like it's almost like I'm not a good guy
for not fucking her,
but someone is fucked up if they do.
It's like if,
you know,
she's like that loaded and you stick it
in her ass.
Come on dude.
Do you know she,
I think she would do it sober.
So it's like,
then I would be fine.
Right,
right,
right.
But anyway,
I don't,
I,
I find like I don't like the older I
get,
the less I like anyone who's not right
here,
like in thinking the same way we're,
we're being.
I just don't like a predatory feelings.
Just never turned me on.
Yeah.
You know where that is too.
That's also
like as you get older you realize like
any kind of confrontation,
any kind of negative feeling that stuff
ruins your day,
clings to you for however long you
choose to hang onto it and any sort of
negative interaction that you have in
another person.
This is bad.
It's just bad.
I tell people that all the time when
like when people start flame wars with
people online like,
look man,
what's a flame wars?
That's just what everybody's like
shitting on people on twitter.
I'm like,
don't get invested in this because even
if you win,
even if you make this person feel
terrible,
like you're gonna,
you're gonna.
This is going to claim to.
I've done it before.
I know the feeling that the insulting
thing and the main thing and the
negative feelings thing and any kind of
weird confrontation that you have with
human beings where one person walks away
from it feeling terrible,
like those things clean.
They hang onto you.
You know,
and it's most of the time,
not necessarily like my job is I have
ego like everybody else.
So it says something.
Someone said it was Shitty,
like as Comedians,
I think just to respond because you're
used to doing it alive room,
but after a while I'm like,
what?
What is the satisfaction eat?
Like you said,
even if you win,
who gives a WHO gives a fuck?
Heres wow.
I made a guy feel worse than he was
trying to make me feel.
You know,
that's not why I got into the business.
I think ended up business to spread joy,
but it's like,
you know,
I'm a comic.
I'm not here to make people feel shitty.
Yeah,
I mean the best part about a show is
when you're killing and the best part
about killing is a whole room full of
people feel great,
right?
Everybody's laughing hard.
You see it when you look out and
someone's face and like,
yeah,
they're,
they're crying,
laughing.
That's a positive feeling and when you
get into a neg,
any sort of a negative situation with
someone that's just as simple as a girl
pretending she just wants sex,
but she really wants to love and then
when she's leaving she feels bummed out
and then you feel bummed out.
And then you get a tax from her,
like was that all that it was to you?
And like,
Oh God no fucking gross.
You know that all those negative things,
man,
as you get older,
you realize you've sort of data chunk.
You sort of add up all the ones that
you've had in your life.
You go up,
I know what this is,
I see this common.
Yeah.
So you learned to back off.
Let's just be friends I don't want.
A lot of times if someone comes over,
like I might fuck around with it a
little bit,
but I don't want to put my Dick in
someone until I've hung with it at least
once or twice.
So they.
This way,
if we fooled around a little bit and
they walk away and they don't feel good,
they're like,
well we didn't fuck.
I don't want anybody.
I just don't want to be somebody Mr.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I've been before and that feels shitty
about it.
I never feel good about it.
Isn't it funny that there's like stages
of things you could do?
Like you hug someone,
it doesn't mean anything.
You could hug a coworker,
you could hug a friend and I'll hug you.
It doesn't mean anything.
Sure.
But then there's like hugging and
kissing.
Oh,
you took it to another level.
Now you touched lips.
Wuh holding hands.
Like you could hold hands with a friend.
Say It's good to see you.
It's good to see.
You could shake hands with someone and
that's just a business transaction.
Hello Bob.
Hello Mike.
No problem there.
You know,
but when you stick your dick inside
someone.
Oh,
things get weird.
Yeah.
It gets a little more connected and it
feels more connected.
They certainly feel more connected to
you.
So yeah.
And if I do the first shitty reason I
know it and I don't feel good about it.
And I'm like,
well,
when you put your Dick in their ass,
like,
this just got crazy.
Yeah,
this has got great.
He just took it to the wild place.
Like,
Oh boy,
I haven't fucked anyone in the ass so
long dude.
And all of years years I've just,
I don't know what it is.
I'm just running out of steam,
I guess as I get
fucking petering out.
No,
it seems like you're being more
considerate as you get older.
It's interesting and I agree with you.
Your perception.
I think you're a pervert,
but I don't think you're a bad.
Perfect.
I think what you were saying was that
you are not a negative person.
You're not a creep.
You're not a mean person,
you know,
that's.
I don't think pervert is a bad thing.
I think it's hilarious.
You know,
like when you start talking about feet
or all the weird shit,
that girl putting her hand in your
mouth,
that's a pervert.
Hey guys,
in a bad part,
like it doesn't,
doesn't make me feel bad.
Like I don't think of you in a negative
way at all.
I think it's a positive thing because
you're honest about what turns you on
what you get excited by.
Yeah.
And it helped.
Like Google is my friend and my enemy,
like when I'm dating,
um,
I really have had a many girls google me
and it just,
that's all she wrote.
He never good.
Like if they don't know me beforehand
finished
because they google stuff and they find
it or not,
then.
Well that's a good.
That's a trooper there.
He got a party,
you gotta you got a great girl.
If she meets me not knowing anything and
googles and then reads,
which you can read and goes,
Oh wow,
this guy's even better than.
I thought.
She's phenomenal.
But that's very,
very rare.
You know,
it's,
it's not.
It just doesn't happen very often.
Well it seems like though they would
find you though.
I mean there's a spectrum of human
beings,
right?
Yeah.
And they would find you like,
well this is what I'm looking for.
Yeah,
I do get that too.
Like she,
like,
like I,
I,
it's a very narrowed corridor of people,
but the ones who do really show up with
their gear package.
Well we say narrow corridor or a people
though.
I mean I kind of feel like that's the
same way with everybody really.
Like when it comes down to like who?
Who's attracted to you and likes you.
Generally it is kind of a narrow
corridor of people,
but most of the time you don't find that
corridor,
you know,
like at least with a guy like you,
a girl can google you.
Yes.
You know,
like some regular guy,
like what are the odds that she's going
to know his sexual proclivities and all
the weird shit he's into and you know
how,
how open he has been about his
relationships on the radio.
Pretty pretty hard to find.
I mean,
so you know that thoreau quote,
I was bringing this,
I bring it up too much.
I know folks,
people listening,
but most men live lives of quiet
desperation.
That's a great quote.
Fuck yet is.
I listened to that quote all the time.
I read that quote all the time.
I think of that quote all the time
because I think it's one of those things
that we just do and we don't address and
we don't.
Especially if you work in the public
sector or you work in business rather,
you know,
you're a guy,
works in an office wearing a suit and
tie and you're acting as normal as he
can.
You know,
it's,
there's a lot of that going on out there
where people are pretending to be
someone who they're not.
It's a huge problem and it's one of the
things that you're seeing these days.
And I wanted to bring this up with you.
Now that you're here,
Jamie,
pull up my twitter profile.
There was a tweet that I posted last
night that I found this guy got in
trouble for a fucking joke and he wound
up leaving this,
uh,
this company that,
I think he's involved with video games.
He's been on Dave Rubin show and Dave
Rubin was a raven and Brown.
Look at this.
Look what this guy wrote.
Let's go click on the one on the left,
right there.
This is what he wrote,
a piece and quiet hashtag a day without
a woman just to fucking joke.
Just real simple job.
Now go to the next one.
Jamie.
Look with the fucking international
business times wrote kind of funnies.
Collin Moriarty resigns after targeting.
Women in racist joke insists it's his
personal decision to resign racist race
known as women or women of fucking race.
Now,
did you know that that a dad joke about
women is racist.
Get some brain surgeons over there.
I'd be.
It's got,
wow,
that's crazy.
Get Some Vac vacancies for real
journalists to click on that,
that,
that quote again,
look at this international business
times.
Fuck you.
Why did he resign?
Whoever this guy is.
What does this guy by Mike like Luke's,
whatever her name is.
Fuck you man.
That is what you are doing,
right?
That is virtue signaling at its very
worst.
You know that's not a racist joke.
That is that what you did is you.
You targeted that guy,
you went after that guy and you did it
in a very deceptive way.
That is,
it is.
If anything,
it's just a joke and you might not like
it.
You might think,
well that's not really good.
If you're working in an environment with
women,
you know,
like you don't want to hear them talk
like that might be sexist.
It's a fucking joke and saying that it's
racist.
Is it?
That is so fucking deceptive.
Manipulative.
At least think I flipped back though
column Loreal.
I don't know why he resigned.
Maybe they're going to fire him,
but what's this guy's articles say,
well,
how does he tie in race and it's got
that he has to have some.
Let's go to the.
Let's go to the article.
There's no,
there's no fucking connection.
It's crazy.
How could there be a connection in
Delano?
Unless that's a race.
Unless women are a fucking race.
It's just crazy that someone would think
that it's okay to do that.
I liked that.
This guy's punching back though.
I kind kinda liked that.
He's not just taking the quietly of
apologizing.
Well,
he quit whatever organization that is,
that he was working for kind of funny
and just decide and so many people that
he was working with shit on him for that
joke.
It's just a God damn joke.
What,
why is everybody so sensitive today and
is it that they're so sensitive or is it
that they're super ready to jump down
other throats because they sensed that
this is a very hostile environment and
when you tell jokes,
people are what?
What are you doing?
Is this it?
Okay when you.
Oh,
he updated it.
And by the way,
people,
I don't think it's fair,
people we took down the word racist as
you described,
is a joke tweeted by comrades,
racist.
It was not.
The article has been changed to reflect
is still,
fuck you.
Fuck you,
fuck you,
fuck you man.
This is,
we had a real problem today and that
people are jumping down people's throats
for jokes and they're,
they're doing it because they sense that
they're soft targets,
that it's,
there's going to be a pylon.
And they sense the pile on the go,
oh,
this guy made a joke about women.
Let's get them.
A bunch of people are going to be
getting.
This is a free shot.
It's kicking someone while they're down.
It's what it is.
It's a drunk girl at the party and
you're sticking it right in her ass.
He basically the same thing mean same
thing with that at all.
No,
no.
But if it's the same shitty mentality
behind it is that people like,
uh,
people,
they don't feel offended.
They just feel it's a chance to be mean.
And you can be mean to someone who does
something fucked up or says something
racist or whatever.
So yeah,
people are just content.
That joke is every episode of married
with children.
It is.
It's every episode.
Pacing client.
Yeah.
A day without a woman.
She's quiet family to come on every
episode of of honeymooners.
So same thing.
That was the war to the moon.
Alice was threatening,
beating her.
I know with his fist,
punching her into interstellar space and
it was so great with that though is
there's literally people would criticize
that,
but she was the first feminist on tv
because she won every exchange.
She was.
She was always right.
He was just a big dumb fat cell and he
was already fucking up,
always get mad and he would always get
mad and she would all the writing and
that the fucking,
the,
there'll be emasculating line.
She had some of the best lines.
I don't want my salary to leak out your
salary.
Couldn't drip out.
Oh,
what a fucking great line.
Your salary couldn't drip out a great
show.
How humiliating.
And you know what?
One other thing about that show that was
so great about the honeymooners.
Well that was the last.
A lot of previous sitcoms.
No,
I mean this is a,
there was a groundbreaking new thing at
the time that was,
it was on the Ca,
I think cavalcade it was called.
It was something like the,
there's like an old y'all.
Last ones were like,
some of them are 15 minutes,
20 minutes.
They were part of,
as a sketch show.
The honeymooners was a sketch in an
overall show.
It'd be like,
it was like dice when he started.
He was just dice as a character and
clay's act.
That's what that was.
Wow.
It just became this thing which didn't
do well and they uh,
came back years later,
but.
So honey,
but you can never do that shit today
where you can do all in the family.
You can do.
There was a million movies that you
couldn't do.
You know what I mean?
You try watching like older movies.
What was it that we looked at recently
that we were lucky.
There's no way you could do that today.
There was a an old movie that was a
really fucking funny movie from like the
nineties.
I remember which one.
It won't kill a mockingbird.
That guy's a bad guesser that
definitely.
You probably couldn't do that one
either.
No,
it was like one of those.
Oh,
oh,
it was national lampoon's vacation.
My good Lord.
I watch national lampoon's vacation and
it's just like there's no fucking way
you could do that movie today.
There you would get to.
I don't remember it.
I've seen this sexist,
misogynist Dick.
Like everything.
Yeah,
like you.
There's no humor.
Humor has to be.
It has to pass like these rigid filters.
Now.
It's not as simple as say something
inappropriate,
but that's still funny that you don't
necessarily mean like one of my favorite
comics and I think a great one of the
greatest of all time is Roseanne Barr.
I really put her as very funny.
I put her as one of the most important
comics of all time because I think that
would Roseanne did,
was she.
She had that powerful fuck you comedy as
a woman,
and it was really one of the first ever
because women were more sedate in there,
even if they were really good comics
like Joan rivers,
that it was a different sort of style of
delivery.
But Roseanne came out like a hardcore
man club comic,
you know,
and she was shitting on her husband for
being a fucking loser or be at fat and
it was just hard and slamming and I
didn't take offense as a man.
I didn't hear those jokes and go,
you can't believe she shitting unmet
can't believe she's shitting on man.
It was just funny to stop this.
That's just success.
And it was so this guy saying,
you know,
uh,
peace and quiet like I'm sorry if you're
not a yappy cut,
that joke shouldn't offend you.
Okay.
If you're a person who's a great
conversationalist and you also happen to
have a vagina,
that shouldn't bother you even in the
slightest and it probably doesn't.
It's just like,
oh,
I know that should bother me,
so I'm going to be shitty about it.
I don't even think people care that
much.
I think they just liked to to attack
other people.
Exactly.
That's what I'm talking about and that's
why fuck you to that guy who wrote that
article and especially fuck you.
Because he called him a racist.
Yeah.
He did that on purpose because he knew
it was going to be clickbait is going to
get people to go to that article and it
was going to get people more excited
about it without even reading it because
all they need is the article.
Most people are so fucking busy,
they don't have time to read the whole
thing.
They're so quick to pull the trigger.
All they.
All they need is the title.
What's the title?
Oh,
that's good enough.
Fuck him.
Let's tweet.
Adam.
Yeah,
let's shame him.
Yeah.
Did you ever interview Jon Ronson?
He's great.
Have John.
I talked to him that had him on before.
Really interesting guy about shame and
uh,
um,
I always feel it.
So I kind of understand that if there's
a weird.
It's just,
it's a good.
Everybody's afraid of people fight so
they don't feel ashamed and have to back
off limit the fucking amazingly powerful
thing like you know,
the reason guys shoot or go on a
shooting spree at work is because
they've been shamed because they had
been fired or because their wife is
sleep with somebody else and the Shaman.
It's the worst fucking thing.
Well,
shame is a new thing that people are
going after.
You know,
like fat shaming and slut shaming.
These are like completely new ideas in
American culture.
This is.
There was no slut shaming when we were
kids.
He never even fucking heard of it as a
concept.
Now we a call a girl,
a slut and that was it.
And they,
they say like,
well girl,
she'll be able to be slots to and they
shouldn't be shamed or fat.
People like,
hey look,
I don't care if you fucking fat,
but if you're sitting next to me and
you're taking up more space than you
should on a plane,
I do have a problem with it because
you're making a decision that's fucking
me up.
I don't care if you eat.
I literally left people that live in a
house and have to be created out.
Good for them.
I don't care if you sit on the toilet
forever,
knock yourself out.
It doesn't bother me.
I'm not going to shame those people.
But if you know,
if you're sitting next to me,
I'm like,
what the fuck?
You know,
it's,
it's look,
being fat is a shameful thing.
It just is.
It brings people shame.
I mean,
that's why there's humor in it.
That's what I want.
A fat guy takes off his shirt and he
doesn't give a fuck.
It's hilarious because like,
that guy doesn't give a fuck.
He's shameless.
You know,
he,
you know,
a guy with a big gut and he's rubbing it
like Buddha.
That's,
that's where it's funny,
right?
Because this guy shameless,
he looks disgusting.
Whereas you or I would look at that and
go,
oh,
that was me.
I'd be so sad.
He doesn't give a fuck.
And we admire him because he doesn't
give a fuck.
Like the fact that he's like,
he literally either he doesn't give a
fuck where he solar shamed devotees loan
to learn how to own it,
so I get to accommodate both.
Some people probably so fucked up by it.
They're like,
fuck it,
I'll wear it.
And other people just don't give a shit.
There are so many weak,
weak,
weak men out there that go after people
for jokes.
Like that guy who made the guy call him
moriarty's on his name that made that
joke.
I'm having him on the podcast.
I reached out to him last night after
this.
I was like,
this is so crazy.
So.
And I looked at all his tweets and all
the people that were piling on.
I'm like,
what in the fuck are you guys talking
about?
This is so mild,
so silly.
Who Cares?
Peace and quiet.
Jesus Christ,
that's it.
That's all takes all it takes for you to
be disappointed with him.
I mean,
so many people,
people that he worked with piled on.
What was kind of funny?
What was the.
What was that?
I don't know.
I don't even know what it was.
He says,
I never heard about it until last night
somebody tweeted to me that thing and
then he tweeted that at me that did you
know that it was racist to,
you know,
to make a joke about women.
I was like,
what is this?
And then I looked into and I was like,
oh my God,
this is so crazy.
What a Dick that guy was to put that
though.
I wonder if he thought it was racist or
he.
How could he possibly.
I don't know.
It's so simple.
It's such a simple joke.
I mean,
there's no room for error there.
A day without a woman Hashtag a day
without a woman and then a peace and
quiet.
That's it.
You see racist there.
It's crazy monsters.
It's fucking crazy.
Anti human monsters.
They want people to feel pain for almost
no reason whatsoever.
Or they will go out of their way and use
any tactic they can.
If they.
If they see that it's in their eyes,
it's legit and it's somehow or another
warranted and it just that goddamn
virtue signaling because somebody's weak
men out there,
that virtue signal they'd like to attack
other men for anything that shows that
they're better than that man.
So you can get a little pat on the back,
a little cyber pat orange.
Hi.
Good people have been doing it lately
politically too,
and it's like,
I don't care how people feel Dr Pollack
fine,
but it's like the obsessive tweeting the
same thing over and over.
It's like they just want people to go
like,
wow,
this guy.
Really?
Where's it shut up.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
Well fuck.
I literally,
I don't have and I just,
I took it out because I tripped on the
punchline.
I'm special.
I had a trump bit and I was listening
and I,
I fucked up.
One of the final words was no way to fix
it because I'm just a dope and I
literally was about,
grabbed a pussy and I said,
drag her pussy voice over it.
I try to because I said it earlier in
the thing and I try,
but I'm like,
just take it out.
Fuck it.
Who Cares?
It wasn't a swan enough,
but anyway,
it was like,
okay,
but I'm like,
I could do this better,
but I'm not just saying something cheesy
and cheesy and fucking know over the
head.
Sometimes when I'm doing a bit like
about something that's real current
events like that,
like I am onstage literally searching
for the words as I'm saying them.
Like I'm hoping that a new word will
come out or a new angle come out or a
new,
a new perception.
Like I'll be able to see,
see an angle of it that I didn't see
before.
And then you know,
sometimes you got to realize also the
bits only have humor in them because
their current.
You have to hit people immediately and
they all.
Yeah,
that guy can't believe he did that when
you have to start calling,
remember what?
No,
we don't.
Unless it's fucking genius.
Like there are some.
Remember Wednesday you could pull,
pull out,
but it has it all like I feel like every
bit or every idea and doesn't even
necessarily just with jokes but in any
subject that could talk about like they
had these subjects have energy to them
and when a subject doesn't have the
energy to it,
it just doesn't and you could try to
juice it up and jazz it up,
but I remember there was a guy to put
it.
That's a really good way to put it
because sometimes I have never been able
to put the words on why does all the
sudden something like it's no longer
topical.
That's a great way to phrase it.
It doesn't have energy around it.
Like in the room.
It's kind of on everybody's mind,
right?
Yeah.
Like last night yesterday we're doing a
podcast and we got to the subject of
Brexit and leaving Britain and I could
feel the energy in the podcast drain
because I didn't really give a fuck
about the subject anymore and it's kind
of a tired subject and,
and it's just been beaten down so many
times and it just,
it seemed like there was no energy in
it.
It just seemed like,
oh no,
maybe if I lived in England it would be
different.
Maybe if I was over there experiencing
the pros and cons of Brexit,
but to me it was like ideas have.
And then.
But we were talking about artificial
intelligence,
the potential of artificial intelligence
taking over the human race.
And that charges me up.
That one gives me like,
oh,
this subject has energy to it.
This is a subject.
This is,
there's things that have,
they have,
uh,
something to them,
like a,
an overall mass to them.
Well,
the word I'm gonna use should make
people want to smack my face,
but some board,
some things have explorer ability.
Yes.
I know I'm a complete saying,
I acknowledged good word,
but like the Brexit,
you kind of explore and it's done,
but like artificial intelligence,
you could always.
It doesn't feel like you're walking into
a room that's already been searched.
Like a lot of times you walk into the
room and say,
I've looked in this room,
I've opened every door.
There's really nothing new in here and
it's boring and the audience feels it.
Yeah,
it is.
But artificial intelligence is always,
you know,
I like dogs.
Do you like cats?
I don't understand.
People like cats.
Yeah.
There's only so many times that someone
can say that until you're like,
oh my God,
I can't do this anymore.
Exactly.
I don't care about either one of them.
I'm done.
People have been.
I've been riding the idea like immediate
pussies since 1990,
so it's time to step forward.
I've always been immediate pussy fan.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I like the bat lips,
back wings.
I just don't understand why people
don't.
Do they wrap around your Dick.
It's like this is like an extra gripper.
Yeah,
I liked that a lot too.
I'm so happy.
I was just chatting him saying I didn't
say it like that,
but no I am and you know,
I was talking to this woman who was
explaining to me how women watching porn
gives him a fucked up self image because
a lot of those women have Lavia surgery.
I hate those labioplasty doctors.
I hate them.
The worst.
It's just so crazy that you would remove
pussy skin.
Like because they don't want their pussy
to look like ragged.
They want,
don't want it to be like hanging out.
There's no pussies.
Never too big.
Like literally you say my pussy is too
big.
Why?
Because sometimes when I'm putting my
shoe on
then it's maybe too big
if you trip over while you're jumping
rope.
If it gets done by the leather rope,
if it dangles wasp legs.
Constant big.
But yeah,
I hate that too.
It drives me crazy.
Like I love.
That's why I talk about it because hey,
it's fun to joke about,
but like winning always will email.
Like,
I love that you liked that because I've
been so I'm like,
please,
I just don't know why it would be a bad
thing.
It's.
I've never understood why it's a bad
thing because some guys don't like it
though.
Some guys like that neat little mean
Anthony's talking about that.
Like always go like,
I like a tight little package.
You don't answer the fucking meat and
potatoes guy.
He wants him naked and a tight little
package and that's how he really likes
him.
Anthony might lead them a little young
to.
Yeah,
I mean he might like,
it needs for other reasons.
He might like,
I'm fresh out of the box.
Yeah.
He also enjoys green bananas.
He likes to pick the coconuts off the
tree.
Really does it over with a machete.
Yeah,
but it was so funny to talk to a guy who
was so opposite me in like that,
but.
But that's.
I almost wish I was like that.
I think that's a simpler thing on that
simpler.
It's just an easier thing to find than
to have these weird little quirks bummed
out if a girl's pussy is nice and tight
and trimmed up and no,
because usually by that point that's
something that our personality I like or
there's something about her scent that I
like.
There's always,
you know,
you got to buy an apartment,
you pick your back.
Like,
okay,
I want it to be in a good location.
I wanted to have a doorman,
but I want to talk about doors.
You're going to get two of those three
things.
That's how it is when you get dating,
but what if you were dating a girl and
she looked like she's,
she's got like good bone structures,
stick almost like eastern European.
She got big hands.
You're like,
wow,
this girl's got have immediate pussy and
you get down there and you see scars.
It's happened.
She's got a trimmed up.
Oh,
I don't know if you'd see them.
You know,
I don't.
I think they do a good job,
but if a woman ever.
Totally.
She had it.
Yeah.
You're looking at like a jeweler.
Some articles like bud from the Improv,
Budd Friedman,
shit,
fucking fucker.
Those monocles for.
I don't know what was the deal with
that?
I don't know.
They would need it at one point in
history I guess and people just think it
looks smart.
Do you think it's just for reading?
Like when people needed to read things?
I don't know.
Like why would you want to have
something to hold it in your eye?
Like one,
one thing like that?
I really don't know the thinking of it.
It looks really uncomfortable and I
don't know.
I would love to know the history of the
monocle now.
I have no idea.
Budd Friedman used to put that fucking
thing in his eye and go on stage every
time we did an evening at the Improv.
Like he thought it was a good thing to
have a Monaco in his eyes.
Probably after a while it's like a
muscle,
like that little thing in your cheek and
just go like I probably just holds it
there.
Like naturally it's like when you have
contacts or leading glasses.
I had like $25 reading glasses and like
I just can't fucking.
I got to go back to glasses.
It stinks.
40th eight.
My eyes are going.
Yeah,
my eyes are fucked.
My eyes.
Are you near or far?
Can you read near like I see you crystal
clear.
When I Read I put these fuckers on other
prescription.
No,
I got to go to a doctor.
I just went and I went to look at the
charts and found out what it was and
that's when I got to do because I bought
like literally a $25 pair of downstairs
at cvs and it didn't work.
No,
they're fine,
but I don't think they're good enough
because I look up and it's like my face
is in gauze.
I'm like,
I gotTa fucking rock.
I pull them off.
They're probably fuck with your eyes if
they're not.
Did not the correct way.
That's why I don't want to make my eyes
worse because I had lasik back I guess I
know 10 years ago,
but that's starting to not work anymore
because you know,
you get older,
you got lasik.
Was it for nearsightedness or
farsightedness?
I can't see far away.
So near sighted.
Far sighted.
I can't see far away.
Right?
Isn't that how it works on the near side
because I couldn't see far away,
but now it's the reading like farther
and farther away.
So that's.
I have a friend who's an ophthalmologist
and he said that it's just one of the
things that happens as you get older.
Your eyes just don't.
They don't focus the same way as they
used to.
I did Dr. Tami,
you're supposed to live.
My ent guy did my sinus surgery.
He goes,
yeah,
the human body is designed to live 40
something years and everything else is
just science and medicine.
So we break down and that's what
happens.
That's why your eyes go,
that's why cancer is happy.
And he was just saying that these are
all part of just natural.
You know you're not.
When you're born,
you're not designed to live 80 years.
God Damn it.
I know where you are,
but the last 20 or supposed to suck.
Yeah.
Or they're terrible.
Supposed to get to the point where when
you're on your death bed,
you're like,
finally,
yeah,
I can't wait for this to happen over
with.
Yeah.
I don't want to die.
I had been thinking about that a lot
lately.
Like I really resist the idea of it.
I don't want to do it.
But do you enjoy life?
Yeah.
Much more now.
Much more than much more.
How much happier?
Much happier because of when Eh,
you know,
in the last couple of years.
Uh,
I mean,
you know,
I'm doing the show with Sam now.
Sam Roberts show together,
which has been a lot of fun.
It's a physic,
you're starting a new thing,
so whenever you get to reset,
like,
okay,
I'm doing a new thing now.
It feels bad.
It sounds like you guys are having a
good time.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We really are.
Um,
and just with doing other stuff with
work,
I just feel kind of more grateful than I
have in a while.
Like with the fucking shut up,
trump being upset.
Fucking idiot.
Like things are really good and when I
fall into feeling bad I know it's just
because I'm addicted to feeling bad and
it's bullshit.
Well,
we have such a fucking great job when
you talk to a person who has a regular
job and they complain about their job,
but then you think about like the
complaints that you have would be in a
comic.
It's like God damn it.
So,
so minimal.
I had a complaint about,
I,
I had like a legit complaint about,
um,
whatever,
the Australian quantas down to
Australia,
they fucked me and I was annoyed that
they just,
they,
um,
the connection didn't wait even though
it was a Qantas plane was late and I
arrived and my manager was on the plane
waiting for me and they just wouldn't
let me on.
And he's like,
yeah,
we already put the paperwork.
Yeah,
they would just be an cocked.
And uh,
they flew me to somewhere else.
It was just a dick blew some complaining
about it online.
But people,
they don't give a fuck.
They're like,
even though it's a legit complaint to
like,
fuck you,
you're flying all over the world and
business shut up and not the kind of
right,
like it's a luxury problem.
It's a problem of,
of okay,
that's not right the way they did it,
but that's not a bad problem to have in,
in life.
It's so minor in comparison to most
things that people go through.
You know,
when you really stop and think about how
many people work jobs that they fucking
hate.
Yeah.
It's probably 80 percent of the police.
The people.
I mean it's probably close to 80.
Well you said the office before things
went through women and googling.
You can't,
if you're an accountant,
you can walk in as an accountant and go,
oh my God,
a massage last night and she stuck her
feet.
My face,
no stinky,
you know,
it's gotta be 12 people,
like a lot.
One guy like interview human resources
and pull you in the office.
Jim,
I'm going to read from a transcript.
You tell me if this is not something
that you said.
Yeah.
Someone stuck their feet in my mouth
last night and they were clean but
stinky.
No,
that was awesome.
And I jerked off under my shirt.
It's not what I said.
I said she put them on my face and they
will clean but stinky none of them now.
I didn't suck them out.
I wanted to clean.
But you know,
our job is we get to discuss anything
and it's so much fun to just vomit it
and people,
people like it because they relate to
it,
but it's a.
It could be a lot worse.
So I think it had a lot.
Like I have A.
I do have fun.
I love doing the podcast.
Wouldn't bat.
I Love Matt Serra.
He's a fun guy.
You know,
he's just the most genuine guy I've
probably known in years.
How often you guys do the UFC
uncensored,
right?
How unfiltered you would do.
How many Tuesday?
Thursday,
Monday,
Wednesday with tape.
And it's just fun to sit with a guy.
Monday,
Wednesday.
You tape?
What do you mean?
We taped the day before it comes out for
whatever reason.
That's just the way they don't.
Just do it live.
I don't know to be,
I will be happy to do it live.
But that was we though.
That was just a ufc his idea,
you know,
I don't know who was damn.
I'm guessing they the bosses,
so it's probably that more than digital,
but I don't know.
Who Do you talk to when you like when
you do that?
If I have a problem or a question I'll
ask craig or I'll go to.
I try not to bother Dana with stuff,
but if there's like a legit question
I'll have.
I'll ask Dana something.
Who Do you coordinate with?
Like when you find out your schedule of
like who's going to be on the show?
We have a booker and I'll talk to our
producer who really is a great dude and
he's very organized and a great prep
guy.
Um,
but if there's something that I think
like,
Hey,
I would like to have this better,
or I would rather we should have this
guest on there in New York.
Then I'll maybe ask the UFC booker or
I'll ask.
I'll ask Craig or somebody like that if
they can help.
And when someone comes up,
when you have an idea of a guest,
you can bring it up to them and they can
book it.
Sure.
Yeah.
We just needed a booker and we have
someone now who is really helping out
like I was.
Do you have to run it through like the
UFC,
like say if you wanted to have somebody
on.
Do you have to run it through anybody?
We keep the,
the,
the producer,
Christopher Christopher Dosa know.
But he's like a guy who's.
He's a little nervous.
Here's the one to get fired.
And I'm like,
they're fine if we have a comedian on
her.
I guess he likes to check it out.
I don't think we need to.
Um,
but it does,
like I wanted Francis and God knew I
fucking love in God.
I just,
he's one of my favorite people and they
pitched him for our radio show in the
morning,
but I was like,
we'll talk to them even though it's
gonna be hard because he,
well he speaks English.
But um,
we,
we actually did the UFC podcast at
different day just so we could have him
in.
So he was great.
That was it.
That's the fun part.
You can get people you want to talk
about.
How bad is his English?
I mean,
I've only talked to him post fight
interviews.
He did not bring an interpreter with
them.
Um,
could we did fade or twice years ago.
And that was rough going through a
woman,
you know,
Patrice was,
and it was really a fun interview.
But yeah,
I don't think that's,
I don't know,
that's not worth it now going through an
interpreter because you also don't know
whether or not with they're interpreting
accurately.
Again,
I've had people say that I'm like,
I'll interview someone after a fight and
then someone who actually speaks the
language,
we'll say that interpreter fucked up
everything.
Like they,
they got it all wrong.
Oh,
that happens.
Yeah,
I guess so.
So we didn't want to do that,
but he didn't even bring.
He just brought someone with him.
He was nice.
He was like,
that was kind of fun.
That guy's fucking scary.
He's scary,
man.
Fucking,
I think here's the one that fight,
uh,
I'm surprised he's number six over
Derrick Lewis,
but it's in the neighborhood it me and
him and Derrick Lewis are definitely in
the neighborhood.
I would do.
I would give derek the nod because Derek
has been more top data.
He beat Roy Nelson.
You know Derek just be Travis Browne by
Kao.
Big,
big victory for him.
Yeah,
I would.
I would rank their boy.
He's fun to listen to Derek Solera and
yeah,
he's a fun dude,
man.
He's fucking.
Instagram is hilarious.
Yeah.
So much shit that he puts on instagram.
You're like,
oh my God.
Like this guy is pushing the envelope.
There's something about.
I don't know if it's because he did time
in jail,
but there's just something about that.
Just those guys like,
Oh,
I've seen such worst,
worst part of life.
This is just.
I can only guess what the.
But it seems like there's a different
mentality when you go to jail and come
out with.
Did Derek do time for.
I don't remember.
It was a three and a half year.
We talked to them about it,
but I don't know if we got into why he
was in jail.
Might've been a parole violation for
drugs.
He was just going down like a road.
I think three.
I don't know.
I believe he did three and a half years.
Yeah,
it's a long time.
He's an interesting guy.
He's getting a lot better man on a kid
is what he was saying in the beginning
of his career.
He was kind of a brawler and then
somewhere around the time when he fought
Roy Nelson,
I notice he's putting these combinations
together and he's got crazy endurance
and then I saw an interview with him
where he's talking about the strength
and conditioning workouts he's doing
now.
He realized like,
look,
I got to have a gas tank keys.
He could put it on these dudes that hit
him and hurt him.
Then he'd run out of gas and you
realize,
yes,
I have a gas tank and now that he has
that gas tank,
you're seeing these incredible
performances for them because most guys
can keep you going through around if
they know that you might run out of
energy,
they can.
At least they can keep you away for
enough time to fucking capitalize on
that.
Travis Brown.
I was surprised that he lost that fight
because he was doing really well.
Yeah.
And Travis had him hurt.
Have you ever seen anybody?
I've never seen anybody hold their
stomach and like Derrick Lewis got
kicked in the stomach.
It was very funny condition.
He had to shit,
but he got kicked and he actually turned
and ran two.
I've never seen anybody actually display
like,
fuck,
I don't want to get hit there again.
I've seen it.
Yeah,
I've seen it map brownstone and a couple
of times he,
uh,
he talked to.
There was also a
drago pete sell fought nate quarry.
Is that who it was?
I think it was.
No.
Scott Smith.
Scott.
Yeah.
Scott hands of steel.
Smith and Drago hurt him to the body and
he moved in for the kill and Scott
knocked him out with one punch.
He came.
He came rushing in because Scott like
grab his body and then as drago is
moving in,
Scott knocked him out with one punch and
then like literally filled the ground
himself in agony.
Holding aside,
it's like one of those rich Franklin
ladelle things like,
like literally at the rounders entity.
Well I think he broke his arm and he
would have won the fight.
You got to look back on that and go,
why didn't I just avoid that fucking?
I was doing so good.
Well,
it's.
Chuck just had that crazy style.
His style was always kamikaze.
It was killer be killed.
Just such a banana style.
So fun to watch,
but man,
that would never teach a fighter that
you know,
you would never teach a guy to fight
like that.
You would teach a guy to fight and
mighty mouse style.
You'd never.
You'd never said,
hey,
fight like Chuck Odell.
I'd rather watch chuck fight.
Even though you know you by the masses,
like the guy is just a perfect,
you know,
but I just,
I just like watching somebody throw
giant fists and fucking knocked people
out because that's what I want to be
like.
If I could be a guy in life,
it's probably better off to be mighty
mouse.
He's probably a more responsible fellow.
I'm probably a more polite fellow.
He probably,
but you know,
who do I want to be?
I would rather be Lidl.
Just the guy that walks in and he's
looking to fuck somebody or knock
somebody out and that's just a funny on
his head.
Mohawk fucking animal.
Look in his eye.
You look at him and you know what he
does for a living?
Mighty mouse might be an accountant.
You don't know what he does for a,
but chuck,
you like,
he absolutely has to do this for living
in the neighborhood.
He's a scary dude.
He is.
But there's a lot of Improv.
I didn't even know him that well years
ago in Dana brought him into the Improv
and he heckling me.
Always downstage being ah,
what did you say?
I played with them a little bit because,
I mean we knew each other casually,
but I was like,
what are you doing?
Ladelle is heckling,
you know,
because you never know how somebody is
really going to take,
you know,
when they're drinking a little more.
Some people will have a bad reaction.
Don't want a bad reaction.
No,
but he was the.
Afterwards we were chatting and I,
he's such an Alpha Guy,
like he doesn't even mean to do it.
You,
I was talking to him in the hallway and
he liked,
he comes,
his arms are wide.
He's like,
Nah,
fuck.
It leans in anybody's being lovely.
But people walking by or like,
what the fuck is happening between the
[inaudible]?
It looks like he's putting you down and
telling you to put it on your fucking
place,
but he's not.
He's just having a fun chat.
Lena gave with his giant Rv.
It's a really fun thing to watch.
I could see people looking who they just
thought something unpleasant,
what's happening?
And I'm like,
no,
I'm just smiling bigger so they know I'm
okay.
I'm like,
ah,
just like when you see a big dog in the
room,
people just go,
oh,
Jesus,
is that dog?
If.
Is that a friendly dog?
Who's dog is that?
I want to take it,
man.
I listened to so many guys that do
Jujitsu and I want to do it so badly.
Want to do it because my cardio is so.
But Matt took me down to [inaudible] and
I loved it.
I walked in,
I just,
I liked the atmosphere,
but I've,
I've,
uh,
I'm too tired and I know it sounds like
such a pussy thing,
but I'm like,
I don't have apnea and I don't sleep and
I'm fucking exhausted all the time.
But you just start doing it and you'll
get better.
Yeah.
I make my all but I will
like,
you're,
you're on a,
a,
a certain level in the beginning and
everybody's level is different.
If you came in,
you were like a world class gymnast and
you know,
you were really good at wrestling in
high school.
You'd be at a higher level when you
started,
but everybody starts somewhere,
you know,
and you just keep getting better.
I mean bordain started at 58.
I,
I actually,
you know,
it's funny I asked him because I know he
started like late and I'm like,
you like,
you fucking love it.
Like he's addicted to it,
so it makes me kind of want to.
He's a weird guy,
man.
Never would have thought that when I
first met heroin addiction.
Well,
will the heroin addiction I think is
indicative of the same thing that's
leading him to Jitsu addiction.
I think he's just a crazy impulsive guy
and not in a bad way.
I don't know.
It's not insulting way because that
crazy impulsive thing.
It also doubles up as passion.
You know,
like the way the guy loves food,
the way that guy loves culture,
the way the guy loves music,
the way the guy loves anything.
Man,
when he and I,
we did this episode of his show a few
months ago and we went pheasant hunting
and we talked to Jitsu.
He fucking loves it so much.
We were,
I,
we were down in the dirt,
like on the ground in Montana and I was
going over positions,
like I was explaining certain parts of
this,
like a lot of times when guys are going
for the Darcy get stalled up here,
but here's another option and we were
going over stuff and like he was fucking
soaking it in man that,
you know,
there's guys that are like kind of like
to Jujitsu and then there's guys that I
started talking to my like,
oh,
this guy is balls deep.
He's all in.
Well that's another reason I want to
take it because I a,
it's for self defense reasons and
because I talk about it with I want to
experience it.
And there's also so many great people I
know that I could ask questions to.
Oh yeah.
It's like almost like when you know all
these people who are great at it.
Well Matt Serra,
you know,
people don't give that guy the respect
he deserves.
I don't think people remember.
But at one point in time,
Matt was one of the Best Brazilian
Jujitsu competitors in the world.
Yeah,
he beat John Jacques Machado by
decision,
I mean it was by decision,
but he beat John when John Jacques was
in his prime when John Jack had one Abu
Dhabi and John Jack is submitting
everybody submitted soccer.
I submitted like some of the best guys
in the world.
You know,
Matt Serra was a fucking beast man.
He was one of those first black belts in
America.
Yeah,
I mean he's,
he was super respected as the Jujitsu
competitor before he ever got into the
UFC.
And you know,
the problem,
Matt,
in some ways it's kind of cursed with
the fact that he has heavy hands.
He hits really hard.
So Matt Wind Up,
you know,
knocking a lot of guys out,
knocked out.
GSP,
knocked out frank trigg,
but maths Jujitsu was better than like
99 percent of the people that have ever
competed in mma.
He loves it so much fun to will you talk
to him and he talks about he has to roll
in that like he just,
he loves it so much.
It makes you want to do it well for him.
It's fun.
He's strangling people every day.
Yeah,
that would be fun.
He's not the nail,
he's the fucking hammered.
I,
I would probably be in a much different
position.
I probably have a much different feeling
about it.
I would be definitely it would at first,
but it's just one of those things where
the first,
the moment you get your first tap out,
you'll be so addicted.
It's so fun.
Yeah.
But you do,
you immediately start.
Like,
I,
I'm such a fucking complaining,
but like I tendinitis and like I
couldn't work out for a year.
I could only do legs and,
and cardio.
So I had this terrible was wrong with
your,
uh,
I had tendonitis and it was like
literally I can't,
I think if I'm doing pull ups or doing
the kettlebells wrong.
Um,
and uh,
I just,
I literally,
my arm was in such pain.
I couldn't do anything with my arms for
a year.
That was when I lost all that weight.
I was fucked up.
I was like,
I'm never going to get fat again.
And I went on this whole 30 diet and it
was,
I stuck to it for like eight months.
What's a,
what's a whole $30?
Pretty good.
It was like you don't feel like you're
eating unhealthy.
A lot of egg whites and common sense
with carbs and you get a baked potato
and some fruit.
Like they.
They didn't say don't eat this,
don't.
It was just very strict.
Certain nuts,
no beans on this shit and I dropped a
ton of late and I was doing all cardio
and I'm just afraid of reinjuring my
alarm and not being able to work out
like you can't think like that if your
arm's not hurt your arms on hurt.
One of the things that happens when you
get injured,
you think you start thinking of your
body's like a race car.
Like you blow a tire.
Like,
oh well I'll go get that tire fixed.
You know,
like I've had A.
I've had quite a few surgeries and a
bunch of injuries that I didn't have to
get surgery on it.
I just had to let them heal up.
But you just do.
It's so fun that you just sort of have a
different way of looking at your body.
You start thinking of your body is like
a utensil or a tool instead of just as
your body.
I mean you think of it as your body as
well,
but like if I break something,
I heard something like,
fuck,
I got to fix this thing.
I don't think of as like,
oh my God,
I can't do this again because if I get
more tendinitis on this elbow then my
elbow will always be in pain.
I don't think like that.
I think,
how do I fix this thing?
Where do I got to go?
Who's the doctor?
Luckily I worked for the UFC,
so I'll talk to Dr Davidson and I'll
say,
hey man,
what can we do about this?
Like what?
What do you,
what do you recommend?
And he'll say,
well,
he and he's on the cutting edge and
excuse me,
he's actually,
I'm part of this team that has started
injecting stem cells into disks,
which is this radical new procedure
where they've been using stem cells to
regenerate tissue for a long time and
stem cells work amazing by the way,
on tendinitis.
Really fuck yet heals it up like it's
incredible.
I did cortisol,
which I know is not recommended.
I did it once and someone told me just
do it once and you're okay,
but don't keep doing it.
I did it once and it actually really
helped and I didn't do anything.
It actually fixed me a little bit.
Oh,
that's good.
Well,
it certainly will help take away some of
the pain,
but it's dangerous because it masks that
pain and then a lot of times guys like
they,
they injure themselves badly because
they don't feel that pain.
Like Bas rutten,
bas rutten chewed his fucking needs to
pieces because he got cortisone shots
and um,
when they were already damaged and just
push through it like an animal,
you know.
But my point is like,
what they're able to do now is they can
shoot these stem cells.
They take fetal stem cells,
they get from a woman's placenta after
she gives birth,
she,
they'd take like a woman who gives birth
by Sicilian section.
They take out the placenta,
the extract stem cells from this
placenta and then inject them directly
and injuries you fucking heel.
It's,
it regenerates tissue,
regenerates Meniscus,
regenerates.
All these different types of tissue can
basically form anything that's injured,
soft tissue,
muscle,
any,
any tendons,
anything that's injured,
it can regenerate,
but they're now doing it on discs,
which is crazy because when you have
disc degeneration,
what happens is your body through poor
posture,
exercise,
abuse,
trauma,
whatever your disks get compressed,
they still wind up pushing on your
nerves and they usually do what's called
a disectomy will they come in and they
cut a piece of the disc away.
Usually it gets worse and some people
either have to get that disc removed and
then they,
they get it replaced with an artificial
one like Eddie Bravo got it replaced
with an artificial one,
or they will actually fuse the bone
together,
which is very problematic.
It puts stress on the upper and the
lower portion of the disc.
Now what they're going to do,
it started injecting stem cells directly
into the disc and the disc will
regenerate and pump up.
So you'll be able to,
in theory,
at least get your disks back to where
they were when you were 18.
So you.
So,
uh,
a little injection of stem cells into
fuck it,
but it's not hurting him now,
right?
No,
I used to,
but I noticed that when I do certain
things like I,
it's almost like I feel like all that
guy,
hey,
like it's,
it's just the beginning of it and I know
what we're going to lift weights.
I do,
but not a lot.
Yeah.
But I mean you don't have to do a lot,
but just lift weights and you know,
progressively build it up and listened
to it,
you know,
if you feel put some ice on
it,
but bill,
late weightlifting,
like it seems,
it seems counterintuitive,
but one of the things that a lot of
people have found is that even Olympic
lifting,
like heavy power lifting cleans and
squats and dead lifts and things along
those lines actually helps joint pain
because it strengthens up all that
tissue and strengthens up all the
stabilizing muscles.
Strengthens up all the ligaments and
tendons.
Yeah,
I do lyft,
but it's not a lot,
but I can't do much.
I get to tuckered out.
You can talk her down like training with
the fucking spit on me.
I'm always like,
I'm tired.
I'll walk in,
I'll let her know what kind of shape I'm
in.
Like I'm really honest about it.
Like if I feel okay,
but if I'm having my days where I'm
feeling like stoned,
who just got to deal with it?
Yeah.
I push through.
I do.
Me and you and I should do a show where
I take you to the fucking gym every day
and we just get crazy.
I would like to caffeine and I would try
that.
Yeah.
One of these caveman coffees,
these fuckers have 270 milligrams of
caffeine.
I'll give you two of these bitches and
then some,
uh,
some Alpha brain and some shroom tech
sport and just going there like a
Goddamn wildman and being some hot pink
satin shorts.
And let me look that scrunchy socks like
from a.
What was that movie?
She's a maniac.
All a dance.
Dance,
dance fast dance class that I always
hated.
That part I saw that goes in and it
goes.
My fucking hated.
That part bothers you?
Yeah,
I hated it.
I don't know why there's certain things
like certain songs with a,
with a,
uh,
with a clap in it.
Like on the big Bette Davis Eyes Guy.
I liked that
she's got bad days,
but I hate with a guy that,
that,
that was so eighties.
The fucking,
the handclaps in songs drove me crazy.
I hated that.
Yeah.
It is funny how songs like you can tell
they're from a time,
you know,
like there,
there's a sound to them.
They'd go,
Oh yeah,
that's from that time.
Especially like 60 to 60,
like that weird.
Whatever the weird sound,
whether it's what Phil Spector started
or these other things that like when you
have been listening to del Shannon's
runaway a lot and there's just a sound
in there,
but I don't let that.
Then you just like everyone who that
song meant something to as a teenager is
old or dead were songs give me weird
feelings man.
I listened to the sixties and the
fifties and I,
I feel like creepily voyeuristic and
frightened,
like I really get weird listening to
those old songs because the connection
they had,
they are in history.
It's gone,
it's dead.
It really freaks me out.
Well,
it's also one of the first times.
I mean if you really go back to it,
but I get creeped out when I listened to
early 19 hundreds music too,
because that's the original music that
was recorded essentially.
I mean,
I think the first.
We talked about this once before,
when was the first record?
I feel like it was the late.
No,
it was like the 17 hundreds.
The first time they came up with one of
those big,
you know,
those big tubes with like the needle on
it and that that was where the sound
came from was that giant thing.
It's not people in fucking in Brooklyn
or buying them because they think it
makes them look really cool.
Williamsburg,
getting those things and listening to
old vinyl on it sounds like shit.
I put final.
What is this then?
The records first.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
The cylinder.
That's right,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's just crazy that when you think
about human history that people recorded
music,
they just had,
they could only write things down until,
you know,
a little bit more than 150 years ago or
150 years ago.
Whatever it was.
It is weird when you look like when
you're listening to you.
Yeah.
I follow.
You want to hear something like,
ah,
Tom Petty and you just download it like
a walk into a club,
Lee.
And the idea that people couldn't record
it at one time.
Like you literally had to just say none
of that song.
No.
Uh,
and then,
and tell somebody how to play it and
they had to hear it and then they had to
play it the way you play.
That's how it got passed down.
The worst is when someone,
you tell someone like,
Hey,
you know that song,
and then you go,
ah,
it's like this,
like,
hey,
been diag.
Sam fairies,
Sammy.
Where his sanity,
like I don't know what the fuck you're
telling me.
And then you play the song and they go,
oh,
that song.
Oh my God,
you weren't,
you didn't sound anything like that
song.
I was trying my best.
Yeah,
that was,
that was not completely unfamiliar
sound.
You are making love to change.
Well,
I don't know that one,
but I don't know what to do.
I bet you would.
If you heard it.
I probably would like really weird
sapping music sometimes.
Like I get really.
I'm a weird emotional wreck with stuff.
Yeah.
I cry a weird shit.
I'm like sad.
I cried at Logan.
I like to try it.
Yeah.
I like to find movies.
It makes me feel like connected to
things like,
you know,
like a jungle fever.
Frank Vincent.
I just wanted to hug him.
I get it now,
but I to it.
That makes me feel like I'm not
disconnected from human interactions or
do you feel sometimes like you are just
a little bit but not.
Not to a point where I think I'm unique
but just sometimes a little bit like
it's always one tick off.
Like I would argue with a woman in a
relationship and I could say barbaric
things because I felt like I was arguing
through a window,
like it was not real life.
It was a movie,
like it was a movie performance,
but then I watched a Sanka commercial.
Oh you hugged the puppy and I'm crying
and it was like,
it was like one click off from where you
should be.
I,
I can remember Bill Burr,
I've been thinking of a lot because bill
bill told me that he doesn't call names,
like he won't call his wife a bitch.
He just doesn't do it because he saw
that growing up and he was as angry as
can be.
He doesn't name call and to thinking
about that a lot,
I'm like,
I haven't done that with every person I
dated and it's so fucked up cause yeah,
it just happens.
They'll say,
shut up here and I'll be like,
you fucking of like,
I don't want to do that anymore.
It's just kind of made me feel like a
shitty.
It's Shitty.
It is shitty and it's too easy to do.
Especially,
there's a real issue when you do it
because you know the person's going to
take it.
You know what I mean?
Like it's one thing if you're like,
look,
you're a continent.
This is done.
I can't do this anymore.
You fucking,
you left my house
on fire.
You Fuck my brother.
It's all absolutely after I jerk off to
the memories on that.
But there's one thing if you say
something to someone knowing that you're
going to make up,
like knowing that you can get away with
it.
You know,
I think a lot of people do that in
relationships.
They get real mean and nasty to each
other because they know the person's
trapped.
Especially if you're married and you
have kids.
Right,
right,
right.
That can get real squirrely.
I've seen,
I've seen that happen with people and
you're like,
cool man,
you got to not do that to each other.
It makes me not want to get married.
Can I talked to so many guys who don't
get their dick sucked anymore and they
don't get this or that,
and I'm like,
I'm not that.
It's got to be a fuck fest if you're
married,
I get it.
You know the kid things.
Dialogue,
but that's my fear is I married
somebody.
A real fear.
Yeah.
All these things.
All of a sudden I know I'm going to
cheat.
I'm not going to be good.
Well,
it's a the the idea of marriage and this
is coming from a happily married guy.
It's fucking stupid.
Yeah,
and this is why,
because it's a contract.
You're your people change on a day to
day basis.
They change throughout the day.
They change based on the song they hear,
they change based on the conversation
they have with their girlfriend.
They change based on a book they read.
People fucking change and you're,
you're in this constant stage of growing
and developing and when you commit to
someone like you say,
like,
this is my girlfriend,
this is my husband,
this is my wife,
this is my,
this is my companion.
When you do that,
there's one thing to do it and to really
be all in and really enjoy that person's
company and want to be with them a lot.
So nothing to involve the government to
get legal paperwork signed and all that
kind of.
I was willing to do it simply because,
well,
first of all,
because my wife's awesome and I love her
and she's a great person,
but also because I have children and I
was like,
well,
that having children is a way bigger
commitment than anything else.
It's because now there's a human life
that depends on you and all my phobias
about government interaction and laws
and legal paperwork.
And this is coming from a guy who has
several close friends whose lives have
been fucking ruined by divorce,
where they've had to pay exorbitant
amounts of money.
It wrecks their life.
It caused them stress.
They've aged 10 years in a year.
I've seen guys like that.
I seen a bunch of guys like that who
have been devastated by divorce and and
then then devastated by the fucking
wife.
Hiring the most evil vicious lawyers to
attack them and go after them and try to
squeeze as much money out as possible
and drag it into the dirt.
Especially when a man and woman who are
married and the man makes all the money,
the man has to pay for the woman's
lawyer and that's where things get
fucking ridiculous.
Yeah.
Because then there's no cost to her to
do anything.
She can file a motion after motion
knowing this dummy is paying for it.
Not only that,
she's draining the money.
She's draining his money and I had a
very good friend of mine deal with this.
He went through,
it was more than a year and a half of of
deliberate where he lost hundreds of
thousands of dollars in legal fees and
the whole time his wife was doing it on
purpose.
They would come to an agreement and then
she would change the agreement should be
like,
I don't give a fuck.
I want more.
And he would be like,
well,
we had an agreement.
She's like,
fuck you,
fuck you pay me.
And then she would hang up the phone and
then the lawyer would contact.
These are the new stipulations and he
would get ready to agree to those and
then she would drag that out for a
couple months and then ramp it up again
and she was being completely
unreasonable and it hit on the
relationship too.
That's a weird relationship.
Even when it's a hateful relationship,
it's still some kind of a connection.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
What people divorce.
Do I have to Piss my pants because I
couldn't make it through a whole podcast
on it,
buddy.
Don't worry about it.
I'm glad you did.
Well,
I was getting too wrapped up about
divorce talk.
He's crazy to think he's going to get
married.
When you talk to someone who is a,
and I say this with all due respect,
the hardcore pervert like Jim Norton,
the ideally is going to settle down,
but you know what it is,
man.
When you don't have it,
it seems so attractive to you.
You know,
like if,
if.
If you're a guy who's got a regular nine
to five job,
you get up in the morning,
you get your newspaper,
you let the dog out,
you say hi to your kids,
you eat your breakfast,
you drink your coffee,
you go to work the same way every day,
and then you hear about rsg.
Fear disappeared and thrown his phone
into the garbage and just traveling to
the middle of God knows where the fuck
he is.
We think he's in Vietnam.
That's what we've heard,
but he could have left Vietnam Tuesday
and gotten a fucking Malaysia now and
who knows where he is.
It might be in Bali,
he might.
He might be doing some fucking
psychedelic ritual with some monks and
the top of a temple right now who knows
conflict three months.
Yeah,
that's insane.
It's great.
It's awesome,
but I don't want to do it.
I mean,
but to someone who looks at light,
like if I was miserable and I looked at
his life and be like,
God damn,
that's what I want to do.
That's what I want to do.
So I think when people just aren't
completely comfortable with their life,
Jim's problem and one of Jim's problems
is he's very smart and when he's
thinking he's constantly thinking,
so he's constantly obsessing about
things.
So you see him like going over all these
variables and that's one of the reasons
while while cry at movies,
it's also one of the reasons why,
you know,
like he'll,
he'll go over all various aspects of
himself.
We're talking about how smart you are,
that it's a problem.
How To pee.
I'll be lucky.
I'll have to go again to my bladder is
weird,
like
it's already 3:00.
So you made it an hour and a half in.
We're an hour and a half in.
Oh my God.
I,
uh,
Ip,
so much that,
uh,
that when you hold it for a little
while,
then your body doesn't release it all.
Uh,
my bladder is a fucking nightmare.
But I buy apnea so bad.
I wake up and have to Piss a lot.
But I think that someone told me that
your body waking you up so you don't
suffocate.
Like when you're not breathing,
your body's going breathe,
breathing,
yelling and your body will sending the
signal pis and that gets you up and you
go,
really?
Yeah,
I've heard that.
I don't know how true it is,
but I couldn't be pissing that much.
Well,
if you drink a lot of water,
you would be.
I pissed sometimes the middle of the
night.
I try not to drink at night,
but I get thirsty.
Yeah,
me too.
I'm going to get thirsty.
I'm like,
I'd rather have a drink of water now and
get up in the middle of the night to
pee.
I love a good beverage.
Yeah.
Why not?
I know.
Treat myself or something like 70
percent water or some.
I know,
but it's making my life almost to the
point of being unmanageable.
I saw logan with the girl and she's.
I'm not kidding when I tell you I went
to the bathroom 12 times.
It's embarrassing during the movie.
During the movie 12?
Yeah.
I have a couple of coffees.
Where do I had my blog?
I've had sonograms already.
Fucking bladder 12?
Yeah.
Maybe how old?
How long is the movie?
Two hours.
Twenty four hours.
You.
That's insane.
It's crazy.
I've.
So you left any every 10 minutes at one
point.
Towards the end.
I did,
yeah.
I'm one I had.
It's a two hour movie.
That means you left every 10 minutes.
Yeah,
I mean that's without exaggeration.
Yeah.
I pissed when I'm on a roll.
It's nonstop.
The girl must be like,
what the fuck is this guy doing?
She knows me.
I told you like Ip a lot though.
He's got to sit in the aisle.
I flew to la the first time I went to La
was with Patrice and I are on a twa
flight and um,
I was in the window and he was in the
aisle,
you know,
for maximum comfort.
Fucking pissed so many times.
And this is 94,
95 and Patrice said to me,
you got to get checked for diabetes,
you,
I think you're diabetic.
And he was diabetic so he fucking
freaked me out.
So I went and got checked.
I had been checked multiple times since
then.
I'm not diabetic and I've had my bladder
like sonogrammed and I like the size of
it.
Different checks and they said no,
it's a normal size.
You just peel it.
You've got a lot of thinking going on.
Jim Norton,
I do too much.
It's too much.
That's one of the things we were talking
about.
You,
you think a lot.
I mean,
it's because you're smart because you're
taking in variables,
you know,
there's a lot of variables involved.
Nice.
I always used to tell that to people
that were,
um,
my students back when I was teaching
taekwondo and they would go to fight and
tournament's and they'd be really
nervous and I would explain that the
smarter you are,
the more nervous are going to be.
And that's just part of reality because
you're aware of the variables.
The stupid people are not going to be
aware of all the possibilities in their
eyes,
in their mind.
Everything's gonna go great.
And that might be good if it goes great,
but it might be terrible if it goes
wrongs in the reality gets shattered
because they can't handle the fact that
it happened.
I didn't see this coming exactly.
Whereas I'm always prepared for the
fucking Florida fallout.
Yeah,
exactly.
You're,
you're,
but you might be prepared to much.
You might be thinking too much about all
the different variables.
They probably wouldn't like.
You're like the whole worry about your
arm when your arm's fine right now.
Yeah,
it is right now it's good,
but then like last week I was there two
weeks ago I was doing these curls and I
and I started doing curls.
Who's got you doing curls?
Oh,
my trend.
I think I asked her.
I wanted to do them and they're not
good.
I don't believe in isolation exercises.
There's very little times in life we're
standing there doing this.
Just lifting things up with one arm.
A lot of time in life I'm doing a lot of
times that leads to imbalances I feel
like,
and as I got older I really believe this
more and more and the more really good
trainers that I've talked to,
the more they sort of harp on this exact
same things that you should treat the
body like a unit,
like it's one large unit and so if
you're going to do something,
it should involve for the most part with
a few exceptions.
It's not terrible to do some isolation
exercises,
but I think for the most part it should
involve most of your body or large
muscle groups like a squat or deadlift
is one of the best because the deadlift
involves your arms,
your back,
your shoulders,
your legs,
your calves.
I mean there's so much involved in a
dead lift.
It's one of the reasons why it's such a
great exercise for overall physical
strength and I think for arms like chin
ups and rows and things along those
lines.
When you're doing that,
like you're involving so much of your
body,
like one armed rose,
it's your back.
It's your core.
It's your arms,
your shoulders,
it's,
there's a lot going on there.
Whereas the curl is kind of just your
bicep and your forearm,
you know,
it's really mostly what's going on
there.
He,
I do a lot of those too.
Those things we get pull into the thing
or you've thrown a punch display or
whatever.
Really robust sizing.
It's not a very particularly exercise
I'm proud of.
When you,
when they have you lifting weights,
are you lifting weights for a high
reputations or low repetitions?
I depends on how tired I am really like,
you know,
it really depends on what if I tell her.
Like I sometimes I say I just want to do
like minor things today because I'm so
exhausted.
It's like,
and I know it sounds like I'm being a
bitch,
but I know how I feel and I'm like,
I feel like I'm going to pass out.
Like I feel like it's like a fog.
It's not even,
it doesn't raise up when you start
working out a little bit.
It does,
but it's literally like s,
like you're,
there's a thickness to it.
It's like looking through things.
I know what you're talking about.
I had sleep when I have sleep apnea now,
but now I wear a mouthpiece.
Right?
Oh yeah.
The mouthpiece is incredible,
but yours.
You got the one that goes over your
tongue.
I want to get one like that because I
have to push my draw out,
which helps,
but it doesn't fucking.
I got the central apnea to your apnea is
a completely different animal.
Your happening is your brain tells you
to stop breathing.
That's a totally different thing.
I also do.
I also had obstructive.
I have both.
You have both?
Yeah.
I have that.
I have that one to Jesus Christ.
That stinks,
dude.
The way the brain one is the creepiest
because obstructive,
all you need is a mouthpiece in is good.
Like I have the obstructive.
My tongue is too big and so it covers my
air hole when I lay on my back and my
neck and it falls.
That's a lot of football players.
Weightlifter.
Reggie like died.
Yeah.
They get a huge,
huge problem with that and a guys like
that also that take sleeping pills.
That becomes a giant issue because then
you don't wake up,
so you have like big ass neck,
big old weight lifter neck.
They live back in your tongue.
Literally choke you to death.
Yeah.
And they,
they take probably the sleeping pills,
I'm guessing because you're so fucking
tired of waking up every two minutes.
Exactly.
And they're always exhausted.
Like I'm getting a good night's sleep
from.
I'll take a Melatonin once in a while.
Melatonin is great.
We have on it.
We have a spray that's really good.
Sublingual under tongue.
Some really great.
Yeah.
I'll get you some.
Yeah,
I would like to try that stuff because
uh,
yeah,
I'm,
you know,
I want to sleep better but I just can't
fuck.
I just don't know what they can do other
than that mask though for,
for that brain stuff.
Like if it's your brain shutting off
your breathing,
I don't get it.
I don't know what it is.
It just doesn't send the signal.
It's got to be a chemical thing.
I think your brain bored with too much
piece.
I'm like,
this motherfucker sleep into a good.
That's probably what it is.
Let's make this more interesting than I
do.
I wake up and I checked my phone,
which will always be.
Keeps me awake.
Like I'll check my text messages or I'll
tell you two in the middle of the night.
At times I will yell a little.
Let's just happened.
You can't do that.
No,
that's very bad.
Yeah,
I don't do that.
I sleep better.
My phone's across the room.
Like you put it across the room and it's
like,
oh cool.
I shut my phone off before I start
reading and then when I'm done reading
the phone stays off.
Oh,
you don't check it before,
but that's probably better that I don't
check it before bed and the only thing I
check in the morning is important shit.
If someone's text messaging me,
it's important but I just do it less and
less.
I mean I think the phone is a tool but
it's also very,
very,
very addictive and being connected to
social media and you know,
having.
It's usually one of my friends do it.
Have you seen this?
And they'll send me a,
like a text message and I'll click on
the link and I'm like,
Oh,
fucking Christ at some crazy story or
some dude who got killed by a bear or
something nutty now.
And then half hour later I'm still on
the toilet bowl.
Now my legs are numb.
And I'm like,
what the fuck am I doing with my life?
Like I got tired of doing that.
And so now I just look at my phone real
quick.
Anything important?
No good.
Leave it alone and then I'll go work out
and I'll go get my day started.
Do you keep your phone with you and you
work out or do you leave it in the
locker?
No,
no.
Well I work out a good percentage of the
time.
If I'm not doing Jujitsu,
Jujitsu is in my blocker or it's in my
bag.
Um,
but if I'm at home lifting weights,
like I lift weights in my own,
my house,
um,
I don't even touch it.
Just leave it alone,
just put it away somewhere and I'll do
it in between sets.
I'll kind of look at it for a second.
But fuck that man there too.
God Damn addictive.
They're too addictive.
But here's the other problem.
People get mad at me because it'll be
like 2:00 in the afternoon and I haven't
responded to their test yet because I've
got 30 of them and I look at my text
message just 30 fucking text messages.
I can't respond to them.
All right.
Don't have.
Because that takes you a half an hour.
Literally each one takes a minute.
You respond to each one,
you've got a half an hour down,
just text messages.
And when you send someone something like
here's one.
I don't respond to,
hey man,
what's going on?
I don't.
That's,
yeah,
not doing that,
not doing that last question.
Nope,
can't do it to terrible question.
I can't do that.
Going on where air breathing,
shitting
Syria phone texting by fuck off.
And you know,
people just like,
sometimes they just want to connect with
you,
they just want to talk to you.
You know,
maybe it's someone I don't talk to that
often and they want to talk more.
They to have shit to say,
you know?
And then occasionally someone will say
something funny and you know,
it's fun to get the if there's,
there's pros and cons,
but it has to be managed and if it's not
managed to get away from you,
I don't manage it very well.
I think that's the problem.
I spent too much time obsessing on it.
And on the computer I discovered chatter
bait.
What does that.
It's like a fucking good man.
They have a,
you opened it up
and there's all of these windows of
people being sexual and you can join or
you can almost watch for free as a,
as a lurker,
but you just can't tip if you're
lurking,
but you can just kind of go in there and
watch.
That seems like a lot of time to it.
It's,
you know.
Yeah.
It's very addictive.
There's other sites like that too.
I just,
that's just the name.
I know I can't do it.
I don't do any of those sites.
I don't look at any of those.
I didn't either for a while at this one
I found.
I was like,
well it was so new.
Like the idea of it was so new to me,
um,
but you know,
I'm,
I'm trying to stop doing it because it's
just,
why not even jerk off at the time just
watching.
It's like weird.
It's like what I dreamed of as a kid,
something human with your kid.
Like,
oh,
someday you're going to pick up that
phone in the kitchen and you're gonna be
able to see the person you're talking to
and you're like,
no,
now I can just open this thing and watch
people fucking masturbate.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
So wonderful.
It is weird.
It didn't believe it.
Your brain is not ready for it.
No one's brain is.
And especially a guy like you that knows
a lot of people and has a lot of
options.
There's almost like too much coming at
you.
Yeah.
I don't know how to manage it.
And I'm so afraid of missing the party.
I'm so afraid of,
you know what I mean?
It was,
uh,
it,
it goes back to.
I remember when I was a kid,
I had fucked up.
I don't know what I did,
but I remember my friends,
you know,
these two black kids there,
I think they were twins,
pr and Randall and they wanted me to go
to the store with them and my mother
wouldn't let me go and I remember
screaming and crying and being so
fucking angry and it was like I was
going to miss something like that.
The idea,
like all these guys,
I like going to the store,
fucking Shit's gonna happen.
I'm stuck with this bitch
was so displeased,
but it was that feeling of missing.
Oh yeah.
This great thing with the fear of
missing out,
you know,
who doesn't have the fear of missing
out.
I love him for dice.
Never fucked.
And I told this story recently,
which is what made me think of it,
is we did a show that I opened for him
from 97 to 2000 in vegas shows tiger
woods came into the show to like time I
ever met him.
I ran out into the lone pine nuts on it
and dice.
They said tigers might come back and he
goes,
let them.
I'm going up to the room.
He didn't give a fuck that the greatest
golf for a live one to come back and say
hi man,
hate tiger.
Go for it and invent.
It wasn't showing that he,
you know,
dice fucking meant it.
Went up to his room and he wanted a
creme ballet.
That was what he.
He didn't give a shit about missing
because in his advice is fucking nuts
and he's the party,
but I admired that so much.
That ability to live without feeling
like you're going to miss out,
we're missing out is this fucking fear.
It's addict is an addict stuff.
I used to have that with this pool hall
used to go to.
I used to go to this pool hall when I
lived in New York and it was a fucking
great place and there was executive
billiards in white plains,
New York and there was always a lot of
gambling going on.
A lot of big gambling games.
Guys would come in from out of town or
were like great pool and people would
sit and watch and it was always
something happened and this was.
I didn't have a cell phone back then,
so this was like I'd be on a date with
my girlfriend.
I'd just be thinking,
man,
there's something going on at the pool
hall right now.
It's probably happening.
Something's going down the street guys
are betting.
Guys are playing probably a lot of
action.
Something happened.
Total addict stuff was really when you
get.
There's nothing happening.
Sometimes there was though.
That's the problem.
Yeah,
once in a while,
but it's the one time there is.
It wipes out the 40 counties.
There wasn't.
Yeah,
it does.
It does.
It makes it worthwhile.
It's like fishing.
You can go fishing three days in a row
and not catch a goddamn thing.
Go goddamn fishing sucks and then one
day you hook a giant Sam and you're
like,
Holy Shit.
Another year of fishing because at one
time it's weird how that one,
the one time it worked overrides all the
times it does.
It's not rational,
but I lived my life like that.
Like,
well that's like people going out and
trying to get laid,
you know?
I mean,
how often does that work when a guy goes
out trying to get laid at a bar,
the average fellow,
what is it like?
Is he like three out of 10?
If he's great at it,
not even maybe one at a 10.
Right?
Ten nights trying to find the girl,
your dreams,
the odds.
Theodicy finding her in one of those 10
or finding a hot girl or finding a girl
you're attracted to.
Some guys will pull it off.
Chris delea could probably go out and
face the handsome guy I.
I give Chris.
He can probably pull a fucking four or
five nights out of 10.
We're pulling home at least an eight and
he's also famous and he's funny.
Yeah.
Funny.
He's got a good personality.
Good looking guy.
He's a combination as another man to
watch.
It's revolting.
Beautiful.
It really bugs me.
Does it?
Yes,
of course.
It's all I needed to date.
A girl who wants to fuck him on the
finished have no shot because he is
funny.
He wasn't funny.
It will be okay,
but if a guy is funny,
he's like,
I can't even get that one.
Trump card I have is that I'm a funny
guy,
but if there's another dude's funny and
he's good looking,
I'm like,
oh well I used to have to give up.
I have to concede defeat,
you know,
unless he's a conservative guy sexually,
like it may be that maybe if she's a
pervert and.
Right,
maybe she's not.
He's not sucking on her hands or feet.
I'm not even that big Ip.
I just found them later in life.
I just think it's fun to talk about
because you beat up people thought,
but I'm not a big foot guy,
but I do ask the size of feet.
Really?
Yeah,
I like them big.
Really?
Yeah.
Why do you like them big?
I don't know.
Piking Morris better.
I'm a greedy fuck.
Ah,
ah.
Do you lose the sound?
Yeah.
What happened?
Plugged the uh,
there's a little thing there.
Has to be plugged in.
I'll probably knocked it out.
We need to fix that with our next setup.
No,
I didn't fix it.
I'm sorry.
We'll get it.
Did I break it?
Oh,
I just knocked that out.
Old Radio tape that was taped.
That special.
Violent.
Hold the tape for you.
I just crushed my legs,
my legs and properly broke the
equipment.
So yeah,
that's the one ace in the hole.
I feel like I got fucking,
I don't know,
but I,
I want it to be like A.
I'm,
my life is fun and I wanted.
Yeah,
I kind of wanted to not settle down,
but I wanted to see somebody regularly.
When was the last time you did that
though?
You had a girlfriend for a while when we
were doing the virus tour way back in
the day.
What was that like?
It might've been 10 years ago.
That was 2006 and seven or seven and
eight maybe.
I had a girlfriend back then,
but after that I dated a girl seriously
to few years and we broke up.
It was just too much fighting.
I'm difficult.
She's my best friend.
I still talk to all the time.
We just don't date anymore.
You haven't slept with her five years,
but we're still,
you know,
she's a great person.
Too much fighting,
too much fighting and everything.
I liked the arguing thing,
but I get obsessed with feeling like
I've been wronged or humiliated.
It's that whole.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
It's that whole thing.
It's you.
Do you realize that you're obsessed with
it and it's not real while you're doing
it?
Yeah,
like if I had to write it down,
I could write it down,
but it doesn't change that because I got
addicted to feeling shitty.
Like I used to trap girls.
Right.
I have a girl tell me like a.
I would make them tell me if they're ex
boyfriends.
Dick is bigger than mine.
Okay.
And let's be honest.
The odds,
the odds were not bad.
Case Strap on and then you would get
upset that they had brought it up or
just be.
It will give me an excuse to hate myself
and feel bad about myself and like I'm
worthless and then that way there was
nothing they could do to make me feel
bad.
I think this self fulfilling prophecy.
And then I dated a girl one time who is
ex boyfriend had a giant Dick and she
timed it before I dated her I,
he said it was like,
there was,
it was,
you know,
and um,
she had a video fucking him and she's
like,
you're not going to want to see that.
And uh,
the way she said it was so sexy,
like a naughty girl,
I wanted to see it and I made myself
watch it and it turned me on to see her
like that,
like to see her being dirt.
Like I took something that was going to
torture myself with and I'm like,
fuck it.
It was almost like you throw your hands
up and you go with it.
Like instead of being ashamed and
feeling bad about myself because of her
past,
take a woman's past and just make it a
dirty part of her that you like.
So then I never gave a fuck again about
her.
Boy,
I don't care who you dated before me
now.
His Dick was bigger.
Good for you.
Let's hear about it while I'm eating
your pussy.
That's what I like.
Tell me all about it.
He would do better,
wouldn't be fun.
Then it becomes a fun thing that you can
fetishize and make good and they don't
ever have to feel embarrassed about
their past or like,
oh,
I can't tell this guy that.
That's a rare girl.
That'll show you a video of another guy.
Fucking her.
Yeah.
But I bugged her for it,
but I kind of knew at that moment I knew
it that moment that it was a make or
break because I had done this my whole
life with girls.
I had set up these scenarios where I was
going to lose and then we're going to be
fucking.
I was going to purposely put a wedge in
between that wasn't necessary that I
didn't want to deal with this girl
because she was super sexy and funny and
I just knew it was dumb.
So I made myself sit through it and see
how I felt about it and I was able to
turn it into a pornography and it was
okay.
And when you said that you knew that you
were doing it while you were doing it,
like you knew you were it while you were
doing it at times.
Yeah,
but not until after because I got
addicted to that feeling,
that burning feeling and the pity or
stomach when you're feeling like you've
been cheated on or you've been wrong.
It was just a stupid.
It was like a,
it was a good drug.
It was like a fucking,
if a familiar feeling.
So you were actually addicted to feeling
disrespected and shitty and.
Yeah,
but not in a sexy,
fun way.
Like now.
Oh the,
the,
a good dose of humiliation makes me
crazy.
But it really turns me on.
Yeah,
it's fun.
Different.
It feels unique.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Uh,
I love it.
Does anybody relate to that?
When you tell another friend?
A lot of people do.
Oh my God,
of course.
Sure.
A lot of people like it.
They like humiliation or whatever.
They'll pay whatever it is or how many
guys.
And plus the women.
A lot of women enjoy it too.
They love telling you about that stuff
because it's fun.
It lets them be who they want to be and
they don't have to.
They don't have to feel like,
oh,
I've got to pretend on this one.
I don't give a fuck what the worst
you've been.
The more you're going to be happy.
I walked through the door,
you know what I mean?
Because it's going to be nothing I do
that's going to surprise you.
Right.
So that's what I kind of like is like I,
I want somebody.
That's why I seek out people in the sex
industry,
I think because I have no judgment on
it.
Like if you do porn or if you escorted
because I feel like you're not going to
judge me.
I feel like whatever you've done,
like I'm okay with it.
Yeah.
That is a big.
That's really important because the real
issue is someone judging you,
right?
Yeah.
You know,
someone deciding that what you've done
is wrong.
I ended a relationship one time.
There was a girl I was dating and she
was one of the girls I met who didn't
know my past or my history of the things
I've joked about or talked about or said
that were true,
that made.
I made sure there were jokes for awhile,
but of course a truck which was,
you know,
and I,
I had to tell her a couple of things
because it's googleable right now and
she's going to,
you know,
trans,
it's going to come up and there's no way
around it.
So I talked to you about it a little.
This is post nuptials posts,
sex.
Have you had fucked?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
We were seeing each other for a few
weeks.
His marriage.
Yeah.
Uh,
I was teaching there for a few weeks and
she,
uh,
she got really weird with it.
She was uncomfortable with it and we
were eating lunch and she said something
to me like,
you know,
that stuff you told me about,
like the stuff you've done with fan
girls or whatever.
Like I had to say it because again,
I'm not going to be with you for four,
four or five months.
All of a sudden you pop it up and going,
I got a question.
I'm not dealing with that on the way to
a wedding or a fucking party and looking
at your dumb face because you don't get
it right.
I don't want it.
So I said fuck it.
I would tell her,
uh,
and she's like,
you can never tell me stuff like that
again because I have an idea of what
being masculine is.
And I'm like,
okay,
cool.
And as she was talking I felt every bit
of attraction to her drain.
Nothing.
I liked it.
I liked the fact that I wasn't offended
by what she said.
I was like,
go fuck yourself.
Yeah.
Finished.
And I stopped seeing her after that
because that was fair that she had that.
But I don't like that scolding shit.
Like don't like that.
Like what?
We all want something when someone
judges you or scold you sexually,
it drives me crazy.
Yeah.
So it wasn't just that she was saying,
Hey,
I know that that's your past and I know
that this is something that you're into,
but I'm not into that.
That's going to be a problem.
Fine.
Instead she was saying that is not what
I think of as masculinity and you are
not masking and I can't shake that
again.
I didn't feel like,
oh I'm not.
I was like,
well,
if she had to put shit up,
put her foot down.
Is that what it was?
I think she just didn't want to hear
about it.
But like,
I don't care if you're into the same
stuff.
I get that,
you know,
I'm not going be in the same things a
lot of women are into.
Apparently the times they want to hold
hands and here I love you and sexually
good luck with that one.
It's not happening.
I'll do it.
Not while,
not in that there's no.
I can't have a loving sexual experience
unless we're strangers.
Then it's a weird high.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
So if you're strangers then you can have
a loving sexual experience that I want
to say I love you or I want you to tell
me you love me because they feel like
they're strange.
Yeah.
Or if I'm paying them.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's like whatever it feels,
you know,
whatever it gets things mixed up a
little bit.
So that's just for a,
for a good time.
Just for a moment.
So like you said,
you think too much.
It's too much.
Do you really feel it in the moment
though?
Sometimes you feel connected.
I,
for some,
my,
I've analyzed this today.
I think what it is and what I don't know
them.
I don't feel any pressure and I don't
feel scared,
but I'm not going to do well.
I'm not,
I'm not gonna be scared.
I'm gonna fuck up.
So when,
when we're connected I feel completely
free just to feel things and be nice.
But once I know you and once I'm dating
you and I care about your opinion,
then like you said,
all the variables come in.
Oh fuck up.
I'm going to do so when there's no risk.
I think that's what I always liked about
exchanges of money.
He was never dehumanizing.
Like I never treated the girls bad.
I was never,
you know what I mean?
I always made them.
I think it was,
I just felt like free,
like I know she's not worried about how
I do so I can be comfortable.
I'm not going to be judged and I don't
know,
it's just maybe I'm just justifying my
own shit.
I don't know.
It's just,
it's interesting.
It's like I've never heard that before
though.
The only way that you can be loving,
and I'm like lovey in a sexual sense is
if they're strangers.
Yeah.
Or if they're inaccessible.
A lot of times it was just about to
chase and again,
it's that addictive stupid shit.
But I liked that one moment.
Like,
yeah,
we all have these moments where we feel
better and that when that girl said that
I felt better about like I was glad that
I didn't go her.
Did you stay friends with her?
Oh yeah.
I'm not mad at her.
I'm not mad at her and she had told me
some sexual shit to it.
I didn't,
it was almost like the shit you told me
that I didn't judge you on.
What kind of Shit?
Um,
she had had a fantasy.
I could say this because he doesn't even
live in state anymore.
She,
I wouldn't say this,
but I still sore.
I would feel bad.
But uh,
she had a,
let's just say how to have an and she'd
never done it,
but she had had an animal fantasy or she
had watched a video of an animal fucking
a woman and admitted that there was
something about it that had turned her
on.
What kind of animal?
Um,
it was a pony
and
something about tweets and
pause.
It was funny
when she told me that she wasn't being
dirty,
she was literally just talking to me
about it.
Well,
it's a big fat hog.
Yeah.
I think I blurted that out front of.
I do with that pony hog.
But she's,
well,
there's a famous,
that's a common fantasy.
Women in horses,
a horse.
His Dick is so big you can't think about
the horse without thinking about it's
Dick.
Absolutely.
When you think about a horse,
like you said,
oh,
chill thing,
it's just like it's a giant Dick.
A horse dicks are fucking huge.
What a great reputation.
So dope.
So they didn't know what a great
reputation they being a horse.
Socks.
Well it's also a lot of women that ride
them.
They're like these Bach and no
disrespect ladies boxy sort of almost
androgynous flannel shirt wearing women
that like,
you know,
they lose their feminine shape and they
like,
they get thick and they just ride that
horse and I always feel like they're
getting some sort of a vaginal
stimulation by just the constant
clop clop,
clop.
There's something about the movement of
the horse and saddle rubbing up against
their pussy and they're just wearing
their pussy out on the wrangler jeans.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's a good way to look at.
I'm Sam.
Yeah.
I never thought of that.
So I think of it women who just like,
I don't need men just ride this horse
and come three or four times as it goes
up a hill.
This giant beast with
Mr. Ed know.
I mean,
I think that's a lot of what it is.
there's a lot of women in my
neighborhood.
I live in Lincoln Equestrian
Do you know the Burbank is an equestrian
neighborhood and didn't know it can be
in Burbank and you'll see fucking people
walked on the street riding a horse.
That's cool.
It's weird.
I love petting horses.
Do you?
They're awesome.
Fucking great.
They're great animals.
I like to pet all animals.
I want to go to a sanctuary.
Um,
I'll be the point with that girl.
I didn't judge her when she told me
that.
Like I always a.
I didn't think he was weird.
I was not my thing at all.
Like I'm not a size queen.
Yeah,
she sure was.
She picked the wrong fellow.
Well she probably liked you for some
parts of you.
I mean that's often the case with
people,
right?
Like you like certain aspects but it
doesn't,
it doesn't go like,
it doesn't all line up,
but you like a few things.
Like he's got a great sense of humor.
He's fearless.
He's hilarious.
He says funny shit all the time.
He keeps me entertained,
but he's fucked a few dudes dresses.
Well she like,
no,
I would never fuck could do to address.
That'd be weird.
Only a trans woman.
There's a difference.
There are Edward was the dude in a
dress.
How would never fuck Edward Trans woman?
Yes.
Yeah.
When you probably like,
did you get excited when people started
changing the differentiations between
like,
uh,
like it used to be like a tranny,
like everybody thought it was a guy.
It's a guy and now it's,
she,
you know,
her.
I didn't care what it,
whatever they,
I thought I felt that we would do is
probably some of the political correct
shit is so fucking irritating.
And then there's times where I think
some of it might make sense.
Not In punishing people but in like just
there is a difference between this
person and that person.
So some of it it's fine,
but I don't,
I don't care.
Whatever they,
whatever people want to be like,
they won't be with Trent.
Whatever.
I don't care.
Some,
some transcripts I've talked to like I'm
a woman and I'm like,
no,
there's a difference.
You know,
you're fine,
you're great who you are,
you don't have to change who you are.
You don't have to say you're this word
because the judgment of the country is
pleasant or for that word than it is for
this word,
but you are who you are,
so you don't just don't say your I,
I personally just don't look at it that
way.
But someone who's 20 would tell me on
the fucking transphobic,
yeah,
I know I'm going to get shanked talk
about in the special.
I know I'm going to get shit for it,
but fuck it.
You know,
if you don't say every word right,
if you,
you know,
if someone's throwing the mines down and
you step on one,
you know you get fucked.
Well,
it's the same thing with the.
We were talking about with the joke
earlier.
That guy got in trouble for it.
So people are looking to get mad.
There's,
there's a lot of that when it comes to
transgender people.
And here's another thing,
like people will tell you if you're not
trans,
you shouldn't be talking about trans
issues.
How about fuck you?
First of all,
because this is a national global thing
that's going on right now,
but you should be able to talk about
everything.
That's my point.
Sure.
But there are people that definitely for
whatever reason,
nature,
the universe has thrown them a strange
set of cards and they really should have
been born a woman and they are a man and
they identify with being a woman.
They feel much better when they're
wearing a dress.
They feel much better wearing women's
clothes.
They feel much better and I don't think
they should have to get surgery to do
that.
I don't think you should have to get
your Dick.
I mean people said,
Melissa,
get your coat off or not a woman.
I don't agree with that.
I feel like if you were a woman and and
you know,
quote unquote trapped inside a man's
body and someone told you that you had
to get surgery to appear whole and
that's the only way you could ever be
thought of as a woman,
but you didn't want to get surgery.
Like,
whoa,
that's crazy.
Like those rules are just as crazy as
any other bizarre restrictions that we
put on people.
So there are those people in the world,
but then there are also people that are
insane.
Yes,
sure.
There's plenty of that.
People who think they know who they are,
what they want,
but they're wrong.
I've asked that surgery question a lot.
I'll ask like,
do you want,
why do you want.
If you want to get this srs,
sexual risk manager,
and I'm genuinely curious.
I'm going to ask you to be like,
oh,
everybody would know what that meant.
It deep into the world.
In my world that's old hat.
It's like human resources are going to
go talk to her.
Yeah.
I forget sometimes.
CIA,
FBI,
srs.
I poked my head out the fucking cave
once in a while.
I'm like,
really?
Everybody isn't talking about this guy.
Go,
sorry.
I've asked about it and I'm like
without.
I'm genuinely curious to what you say.
Like I don't know the answer to it.
So I'm like,
do you what?
Do you want it?
And sometimes the answer is like,
I think it will feel better and that's
one thing.
And then other girls as well,
this way I can go swimming.
And I'm like,
but those were all outside things.
Other people's judgment.
That's not like I feel a certain way
that's other people will look at me more
this way.
So that's a dangerous thing I think.
But if it's going to feel better and
this is how I want it to be,
that's the one thing.
And they can't come though.
That's the other thing.
There's no orgasms,
right?
I don't know.
I your Dick removed.
I'm pretty sure the orgasms are done.
I've heard,
I've heard different answers from
different people.
So I,
I just,
I don't know the answer.
I was in a funny that that's terrifying
to people as a thought to no longer be
able to have orgasms.
How many orgasms even having a week.
You know what I mean?
If you have like four or five orgasms a
week,
whoa,
there's not that many,
but not considering the 24 hours in a
day.
All the moments in a day.
The few moments that 30 slash 40 seconds
that's so important to people to lead up
to.
It's fun though.
Like I liked it that I get addicted to
the lead up and that's what you can keep
going for awhile.
You were the first person to tell me but
edging but edging.
Oh yeah.
It's great.
I never heard about that,
but we would get close and then stop,
get close and then stopped.
Awful.
It really is.
I wish I didn't do it because then sex
becomes this weird thing,
but uh,
you know,
I got addicted to doing that when I
don't do it for a while,
then I just kind of feel normal now.
When you do a show like this and you get
real open about this kind of stuff,
do you get a bunch of freaky chicks just
start bawling?
I think because again,
with,
with on the radio show in the morning,
there's enough people who have,
who known me or it's not surprising to
anybody.
I don't fucking.
I was talking to this girl on instagram
and she was,
uh,
she was trans and I was following her
and she wrote me this,
this a private message and she's like,
I didn't even know who you are.
I had to look you up.
Which is weird.
Like,
all right,
fine.
I didn't say,
hey look,
it's me can,
I'll shoot you down a little bit for no
reason.
I didn't do anything to it.
That's natural.
And then she's like,
that bit you did on strap on is very
disrespectful to trans.
I'm like,
Oh,
first of all too true story.
You think I'm proud of the fact that a
fucking I cut.
I just two different strap on stories I
have and I've told them both and
specialist at both trope and I'm like,
they're not,
they're true stories.
It's like you're trying to act like you
don't like trans girls,
but it's obvious you do.
And I'm just like,
oh,
you fucking dope.
You not reading the situation.
Right?
Of course,
you know,
no one thinks I don't know one.
And I'm like,
I sent her an interview from vice where
I talk about it and then she blocked me.
He blocked her.
She did.
Nobody wants to be wrong.
She like an idiot.
She was just trying
to get mad at you for no reason.
And she'd want to be proven wrong.
People are so stupid.
They get mad.
They liked to get mad.
Just like you were talking about,
you were addicted to causing these
situations.
I'm a twitter troll and a relationship.
That is what it is,
right?
Yes.
I'm addicted to that feeling.
I'm addicted to that.
That rush and that high.
That's exactly what I do.
Isn't it funny that the president is
twitter as a twitter troll?
Oh my God.
Yes.
And it's a twitter troll and I don't
even say whatever you want about him.
I don't hate him,
but his twitter and as embarrassing,
he's got to stop.
He's a legit twitter,
twitter troll.
Weird word to say 10 times.
But twitter,
twitter,
troll,
twitter troll.
Yeah.
Really?
Uh,
he is an odd,
odd duck.
He's a troll.
He likes to troll.
I mean,
him and Rosie O'donnell still go at it
almost every day,
or at least rosie goes out.
It srosy backed off for a long time,
but now that he's president,
didn't she back off when he said he was
going to sue works?
I think she had said he was broke or he
went back.
She said something which technically,
and you don't want to have to litigate
with a guy with a billion dollars.
I mean,
that's a frightening proposition.
I think she apologized on the view or if
I was wrong,
which is probably a smart move.
Well,
that was when she started mocking him on
the view because he had done this thing
where the Miss Usa.
Which one does he own?
Miss Universe.
I don't remember.
He owns one of them and he had made some
sort of distinction that the woman,
I forget the specifics,
but she had done something inappropriate
or what he deemed inappropriate and she
was getting her crown removed or
something like that.
So Rosie O'donnell was mocking him and
she's mocking his hair and the way he
behaves and the whole deal and she went
on this long rant about him on the view
and then he went on Letterman and shit
all over her and then they went back and
forth and back and forth.
And then I saw she made a poem because
he had mocked her during the debates.
Like when one of the things that drove
me crazy,
because I'm a.
When Hillary Clinton was debating him,
she said,
you have said this about women,
you know the women in this woman's a pig
and a sweatshirt.
Okay.
But about which one?
Like,
well you can't say women overall in
general.
She knew what she was doing.
She was,
she was trying to find like this hot
button issue.
And he's like,
well,
you know my center about Rosie
O'donnell.
And so she was devastated by that.
She was watching it at home and wrote a
whole poem about the sadness creeping
in,
how it was bothering her and the whole
deal.
But now she like kind of bates him,
like he,
he made a post yesterday about all the
jobs that have been created and erode
jobs,
and she retweeted it,
quote,
tweeted it and said trees and trees and
trees.
And I'm like,
all right.
Yeah.
People really don't have set this one.
I'm in jail.
I'm like,
I love being alive.
I love watching it.
It's fascinating.
Love it.
It's fun.
It's all these protests.
Yeah.
Get in front of the trump towers and
fucking scream.
I know in our studio is not far from
there.
So when the Uber driver decides to go up
first avenue,
I normally hit traffic crossing town.
It's like,
hey dummy.
Go Up the other way.
It's recreational outrage.
Yeah.
I think so many people that are out
there in front of his building.
The hotel in your hotel at UFC $200.
Phone.
We had to walk home.
Fuck,
that was married.
That was fun.
Yeah.
We walked from my hotel all the way to
the UFC because we could not get a
fucking car to take us.
There was no car,
so I had to put a hood on and just
fucking barrel down and just plow
through other people and then when we
started getting close to mass square
guard,
it started getting a little crazy
because people recognize us.
It was getting a little squirrel.
You.
Yeah.
For you it's very hard,
but you,
you walked very purposeful purposefully.
You know,
you have a,
you have a way of getting in and out,
uh,
because you got to.
If you stopped going to be a fucking
fight,
you gotta tell people you can't stop
people that came in.
I take a picture.
Hold on a second,
hold on.
Let me get back picture.
And they can't do it.
Stop.
Can't stop.
There's 50,000 people on the street.
There's no way I could stop if I stop
them fucked.
Yeah.
I've seen it.
Take one comes over.
Then it's just two minutes.
But it was this feeling in the air too.
It was just such a weird feeling.
It's like it was almost festive.
Like people were festive in there
protesting.
It's almost,
they're giddy excited.
We're together.
Fuck him.
But meanwhile,
you're not doing anything,
you're just yelling and you know this
one guy,
I've told this story before,
but it was just so bizarre because he
was screaming out,
Donald Trump KKK,
racist,
sexist,
anti gay.
He had this whole thing that he was
screaming out and then he sees these
black guys walking towards him and he
starts yelling out black lives matter.
Black lives matter.
He changed his rant.
Fucking Douche bag.
So gross.
He was such a,
such a thin boned,
liberal,
such as the kind of guy who would cry if
it was,
if they were camping and they ran out of
water.
Just that guy.
Frail.
Nice.
He was so frail.
He was not just frail.
He was just everything about it though.
The hole,
the chant,
you know.
First of all,
this whole racist,
sexist,
anti gay.
Let's just start with anti gay.
Like where?
Where's the evidence?
Are you sure?
He's anti gang.
Like what has he done?
Really?
I don't think he cares.
I don't think he does either.
It's unless it's making him money or
losing money.
There was the thing about people trans
rights to be able to use the restroom
that they identify with,
you know,
that that was a hot button subjects and
there was actual government support for
people to use the bathroom that they
identify with.
And boy that is a tricky one.
That's when I,
I'm not sure if either,
you know,
I feel like that one,
there almost should be three bathrooms.
Yeah.
Like male,
female and who gives a fuck?
Yeah.
We're pull up,
put them all in when you can have them
all as single bathrooms,
gender neutral,
neutral.
That's fine.
But then businesses go yet we have men
and a women's room and it's like we just
established he's in the bathroom now
what you want us to pay $100,000 to have
a new bathroom.
Put it like.
And there were people that were
arrested.
A few guys who were arrested for saying
they were transgender and they were
sleeping and taking pictures of women.
You know,
it's like there are creeps out there and
that's that scary.
Yeah.
I mean,
and then people say in rightly so will
those creeps should be punished on an
individual basis.
Right,
but that,
that puts that up to law enforcement and
then you have to have more resources to
make sure that these guys aren't doing
that creeping around and female
bathrooms and pretending to be
transgender.
It's like,
man,
when you,
when you have an opening for creeps,
they're gonna find their way through
those cracks and that does not
necessarily saying that because of
creeps,
you should punish transgender people,
but I want to.
I'm not sure of the answer to that.
I just don't know the answer.
Like I,
I don't like the law that they made was
North Carolina.
It's a little shitty,
but I do.
It was the law in North Carolina.
They just said basically you have to use
the men,
men and men.
They just said you can't do whatever is
on your birth certificate.
Right?
Yes.
And get that changed.
I think you can get your birth
certificate changed.
That I don't know.
I don't know the answer to that.
If you can,
can you get the gender on your birth
certificate changed Google that I think
you can.
Maybe I think you can,
but as there a legit complaint,
like if women are in the locker room and
someone is legitimately trans,
is it,
is it odd for them to see somebody
walking around with car like I could get
with that would be weird and without
being transphobic,
it's just not something you expect to
see.
In the lady room.
The majority of states permit the name
and says to be changed on a birth
certificate either through amending
existing birth certificate or by issuing
a new one.
Many states,
however,
require medical proof of sterilization
by sex reassignment surgery.
What proof of sterilization?
Sex reassignment surgery in order to
warrant a gender marker change.
That's a weird.
Yeah.
You got to get surgery for the state to
agree with you,
but not just that sterilization well
bisects your sterilized by the
reassignments.
I know,
but that's a weird way is describing in
many states,
however,
require medical proof of sterilization
because guess what?
Female to male does not make you
sterile.
Like when when women start taking a male
hormones,
like there was a one where there's this
guy with a beard and he was
breastfeeding.
It was crazy.
Oh yeah,
got pregnant,
gave birth and was breastfeeding and
then people were saying,
well what kind of,
what does this kid getting?
Like what?
What's going on?
And I mean this guy's taking exogenous
hormones and this kid is sucking on his
tits.
Like,
yeah,
I wonder.
I don't know,
maybe it's maybe it's not bad for the
baby or maybe stopped.
I have no idea.
It gets a little dicey and you know,
like there's this big hits in the
country,
but it's like other people if say,
all right,
we're trying,
we're not everyone's.
This is a tricky one.
People are just trying to learn what it
is and get used to it.
And Science is not even 100 percent.
So give people some fucking time to
adjust.
Like everyone who's not 100 percent on
board is not trans phobic.
Some people are,
some people who are learning to
differentiate that just because a guy
says tranny,
sometimes they're not true doesn't mean
he hates transpeople.
Who's transphobic?
Learn the difference when you're
labeling everyone who is not 100 percent
onboard,
transphobic.
You lose so many people who would be on
your site.
Well,
I think like many things with human
beings,
people are messy.
This is messy realities to all of.
And I think that's what's going on with
the whole transgender issue too.
You know what I mean?
That's.
People are messy,
you know,
it's just the whole thing is we were
weird,
man.
We're everything about us is weird from
education to marriage to gender
relations to the roles that we choose.
Like there was some fucking tweet that I
saw today.
Um,
oh,
smashing social justice.
This is what it was.
Go go to smashing social justice on
instagram and this is like this.
It just shows how bizarre the way people
think.
There was a line in front of the women's
room and no line in front of the men's
room.
And I think the quote was,
I'm more subtle.
Patriarchy bullshit law.
Twenty minute line in front of the
women's room.
No line in front of the men's room.
Like,
no,
that does nothing to do with the
patriarchy.
That has to do with women need an
individual stall.
It requires more,
more space.
Oh No.
Account accounts private.
It's a private.
Oh Wow.
Weird.
They're probably getting a request
request to join you.
Fuck,
you got locked out.
What?
I'm not logged in on this.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
That's interesting though,
that it's a private account.
Must Be.
They get hated on by people.
That's funny.
Yeah.
I don't.
I tend not to.
It's funny on twitter,
even when I've seen a few really
annoying things in the last month or so
and,
and uh,
they're not at mentioning me and I'm not
following them,
so I don't address it.
They're not talking to me.
I kind of practiced what I've always
preached.
Like if I'm not,
if you're not following me,
go fuck yourself.
I'm not talking to you.
Well this people that will say mean shit
to you that aren't following you.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Try to get your attention.
But what,
who are those people?
Like why would anybody,
unless you've done something egregious
or you've put something out,
like say like if you wrote a book and
you're like,
trans people should all be shot and make
the world a lot.
That's something that someone should
address and them to doing that and
making a big deal out of it makes a lot
of sense.
Putting their foot down.
But,
but again,
it's like what we're talking about with
that guy and the joke like pe people are
not necessarily making points that are
just looking to be offended.
Recreational outrage.
Yeah.
Like,
like,
like a dumb guy laying there on his side
saying,
so you're saying that there's cock was
bigger.
So you liked having sex with him?
I would walk them to the logical steps
just to get them to say paint.
That's all I would lie on your side.
Oh yeah.
So we were in bed.
I remember being in bed with one girl in
particular,
unless I just discussing it in Florida.
Literally posting.
Do you ever see the clip of.
And this is where trump was not media
savvy enough,
or Chris Matthews,
I think it was painted into a corner
about abortion.
So should they be punished for having
like he just didn't.
He's a smart dude and he just did a real
media savvy guy thing that trump is a
non politician,
wasn't,
didn't give a very good answer to which
was about abortion being illegal and he
logically walked him into a corner and
then trump had to go the like the only
answer was he had to put him in jail.
So that's what I would do to.
But just to get them
to say bad shit on a fucking idiot.
Did you see that one reporter that
backed him into a corner when it came to
the amount of electoral votes?
Like how big his electoral victory was?
I do not.
I don't know.
He was.
He was doing this thing that he does
where he brags,
which he's a braggadocious man,
but you can't do that once you're the
fucking president.
It's got to change your ways and you try
to stop freewheeling.
He free wheels up there.
It does.
And you,
you get,
you tie yourself up in knots and all the
shit that he was allowed to get away
with his whole life.
Now those become a liability and he was
just talking about the electoral college
victory.
And this guy said,
you said that you won by the largest
margin history.
In fact,
that's not the case.
And then he goes,
well,
I meant by Republicans.
And then he,
he,
he says by Barack Obama.
And then he says,
well,
George Herbert Walker,
Bush,
Bush won by a far larger margin than
Obama won.
He says that.
And he's like,
well,
you will agree though that,
uh,
I won by a substantial number.
He just can't say he's wrong.
I did see that the guy was standing up
at the press conference.
He had a guy and he goes,
I said,
people told me that you can't just
sometimes you just got to go.
I was wrong.
Yeah.
People don't mind when you say it,
but he,
the guy had a point there.
The reporter had a really good point.
The point was,
if you want to point at all these media
outlets and say they're fake news and
they're giving bad information,
how can we listen to you when you're
giving bad information?
I mean,
that was a great point.
He shouldn't.
People when you.
When you say maybe because people don't
let you off the hook,
but if you say you're wrong about
something,
hey,
I made a mistake.
People have a tendency to look at you
and like you for that because nobody,
nobody thinks she didn't.
Of course,
of course everybody knows you did own up
to it.
We're all human.
No one's perfect.
I'm always a person on bad.
That's all I'm saying that he should
know everybody's bad at it.
Well,
I shouldn't say everyone.
There's a great.
Many of us are very bad at that.
Yeah.
It's a very hard thing to admit,
especially if you feel like you're being
challenged.
It's very hard to admit that you're
wrong.
Yeah.
I like to just go,
hey man,
I made.
I made an error.
I shouldn't have done that.
Yeah,
but it's that feeling like I lost the
exchange.
Yep.
Instead of winning a lot,
but then when you got to learn how to
lose.
Yeah,
that's one of the good things about
Jujitsu.
You learn how to lose.
You Do,
right?
You have to.
Everybody's put tapping.
You get tapped all the time.
Especially in the beginning.
Yeah.
I said I'm going to take to just do it.
I'm only going to take it until I get
tapped that unfinished.
Taking it for one day,
then.
Yeah,
no,
I really want to do it.
It really wasn't a true the entire.
Because when I went to,
you know,
it's like you walk into a place,
you get like a vibe,
and Matt walked me in and.
And do you think the mayor sure everyone
loves this guy and or even,
oh,
he's so great governance.
Jujitsu state,
and they love him.
Everybody does.
He's the most,
probably the most genuine guy.
There's no bullshit in this guy.
Yeah,
he's,
he,
I love Matt because he hates bullies.
Fucking hates bullies.
He's one of those guys who just doesn't
tolerate a guy who.
He's a short guy now.
Probably people fuck with him.
When he was younger,
he said that he just can't stand it.
That's probably a lot of guys.
That's what leads them to martial arts
in the first place.
George St Pierre the same thing.
Just not just tired of being bullied.
Tired of people fucking with them,
you know?
Well,
he walked me in a dangerous place and I
really liked the energy in there.
The people are so,
so it's something
I'm going to do places.
Sorry to interrupt you,
but if this one of the best places in
the world and in your neighborhood,
I know it's not far.
It's a few minutes.
One of the best in the world.
People travel from other countries to
come and train and Benzos.
They do 100 percent.
John Donner.
Oh yeah.
He is a fucking genius.
He's.
He is one of the most respected guys
introduced it today and what they call a
Donna,
her death squad,
like all those guys like Gary Tone and
all.
Eddie Cummins is so many really great
jujitsu players that he's.
He's training and mentoring in that one.
Jim,
like that one place.
Hence those places.
One of.
Absolutely.
One of the most respected places in the
world and I think today or yesterday,
it's his birthday.
So happy birthday.
Let them great because come on on filter
filtered a couple of times on the way
and that will bring them in as a cohort,
but I've never asked.
Oh,
that's awesome.
Yeah,
I want to,
I want to sit with him.
Um,
but I,
I really liked the energy and the people
were very nice and it was like you walk
into a place,
you're like,
I could see myself being here.
I couldn't,
but I didn't feel nervous or
uncomfortable on that.
This is a place I could come and learn
this.
I would love to.
Yes.
When you talk about it,
even like talk about it.
I'm not a fucking expert on it.
Like you want to know from experience
with certain things feel like.
And I,
it would make me more knowledgeable just
so you are always having people strangle
you just for the field.
But I respect it so much more after
that.
Like when you feel it came last.
Just puts a fucking a fucking a
guillotine.
Choke her.
Yeah.
For a second you're like,
Oh,
you guys do that with the intention of
hurting you and choking you out in a
real fight.
Staggers me.
Like when Jon Jones,
the worst one I took was fucking Joe.
That big Jon Jones,
Shannon my leg.
But I told you I felt like I had to shit
my body.
This video of it.
I was very fat.
When that happens,
that buck and I literally,
I was.
My Body just says,
here it is.
Let's get some volume.
Oh
Shit.
It's fucked up
that.
I mean he barely hit you.
He didn't put full strength with that
was.
That was like fight week sometime.
Don't get them on fight way to do it
because our order ramped up cutting
weight and not happy,
but he didn't even hit you hard.
He didn't even hit your heart on it.
It's going to choke you with a different
outfit.
This was a second horrible.
The way he's doing that.
That's a horrible joke.
Oh,
that's
horrible.
That's a horrible joke because he's
going,
that's an esophageal style.
Guillotine choke because he's.
He's using the bone of the forearm
across the front of your neck.
Yes.
He was the worst.
That's the most painful of the
guillotine.
Chokes.
Yeah.
He did it.
And uh,
the,
the kick,
they'll hurt me that the leg one your
body.
I felt like I had to.
I had to go to the bathroom.
Actually.
I thought I was gonna vomit.
I had to go to the bathroom and splash
water on myself like that.
I literally had to put one on my face.
I was like,
I might pass out.
It was because my body had not been.
It was like a shock to the system and I
hadn't felt that before.
Were your nerves to like slams into that
meat of your or your thigh and all those
nerves that run down the side of your
leg are all impacted and your whole
system just gets jacked dude.
But then you watch someone like Edson
Barboza kicking people like that lot and
I'm like,
this is a guy.
There's a guy standing there who knows
this is coming,
takes it.
And he continued.
Well that's a different thing because
you're so pumped up with adrenaline.
You're in the middle of the fight.
I mean those guys are in agony
afterwards though,
for sure they're walking out of there
and deep,
deep,
deep pain.
But to have felt any remote,
even if it's a 10 percent to a,
felt that at all and then know that
when,
when he's doing that,
because he wants to fucking put you out.
He's doing 100 percent.
You know what you should do.
You should do it for your show.
Were you like decide to like if you
filmed it,
if you filmed like your first day at Hen
Zos and like do it on a youtube channel
and a and go out there and do you have a
youtube channel?
You have your own youtube channel and I
don't do much with it.
I do more on the radio shows one now.
Just really put our episodes up.
But just do it though.
Have somewhat common film.
You taking your first class and have
someone you know,
put it together,
make a 10 minute little video out of it,
and you talking about what it's like.
Take your first Jujitsu class and then
commit to it and do it three times a
week.
Yeah,
I would like to do that because there's
a couple of days I could do it right
after the gym.
And don't do that.
You shouldn't.
No,
no.
You'll be too tired.
You're going to lift weights and then go
do Jujitsu.
You're going to get fucked up.
That's why I do the gym four days a
week,
so that's four days a week.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
Monday,
Tuesday,
Thursday,
Friday.
That's awesome.
That's really good,
man.
That's really good.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm dumb schedule.
I go like right after radio.
Oh,
okay.
And then.
Well if you did Jujitsu at night,
that'd be fine.
If you give yourself a few hours to
recover.
Yeah.
I totally stand up though because I
might schedule stinks.
I'm up at seven on the air at a to 11
fucking Jim,
you have a crazy schedule to two days a
week.
Did you decide to do morning radio again
because didn't you guys have the
opportunity to do it in the afternoon?
We wanted the mornings.
There's more people listening in the
morning,
but it's also because I became so used
to it that I wound up when I travel,
there's travel days,
man,
that I would miss out.
Like if I have to leave Thursday for
Friday Gig,
I don't want to miss Thursday and
Friday.
Shell and the guests are better in the
morning.
The better.
Yes.
There's more people in the building,
but I.
But I have afternoons is fun.
Seminar.
We pre pre-taped last night for this
morning show.
Just I was so fucking tired.
I knew I was coming here and I go,
I just wanted to do it.
It's hard to get good guests in the
afternoon.
Yes.
Because a lot of times the good guests
that you're going to get in New York,
they're doing fallon,
the dual,
uh,
found that doing a Kobe.
So by,
by three or 4:00 get amped up to go into
the studio.
Oh,
Cole bears in New York to studio.
Okay.
Yeah.
Thanks Seth.
Meyers Meyers and they will get good
guests but it's just we get,
I'd say 70 percent more people are
coming through in the morning plus
Howard's in the morning,
so like sometimes people come in and do
him or they'll do this or that and he's
got to show know it's a plus.
I just,
it makes me feel like I can go to the
gym if you let me sleep all day.
I'll wind up getting up at fucking 1:30.
I'll be on the air by [inaudible] till
seven and then I'll go fucking do spots
and then I'm up all night on the
computer like I'm up to no good that
time.
You know what I mean?
Because you can't go and take Jujitsu at
1:30 in the morning.
If that was an option.
I do.
Afternoons,
it seems like there would be a place
where you could do Jujitsu in the 1:00
in the afternoon or 1:00 in the morning.
Once I'm up,
I just got to go like Monday.
Monday is my busiest.
It's,
it's,
it's fucking radio.
Jim unfiltered.
And I'm home by like three or 3:30 in
the afternoon,
so I feel like I get a lot done.
And do you go out that night and do
standup on Monday?
I'll do two sets because there's a
regular set at the cellar and around the
corner.
They have new joke night.
A will.
So then it's runs new joke.
Dayas a great show.
Oh Nice.
So how many nights a week are you doing?
Stand up?
Six or seven?
Not whoa.
Yeah,
almost every night.
Um,
I'm working on because the special comes
out today.
Oh,
that's right.
That's right.
And uh,
I'm,
I started,
I shot in December,
so I've been since December working on
material just to get it sooner.
Like loud.
I got a new 35,
you know.
Right,
right,
right.
I just drop it as soon as I'm done,
I shoot.
Just think of it right by that point
you're like enough.
Jerry Seinfeld did the Improv the other
night and did 20 year old jokes did he
did a set,
did a couple of new bits and then he did
jokes from like 20 years ago.
Really in a couple of my friends were in
the audience know like what is he doing?
Like why is he doing these jokes that
everybody knows and I guess in his eyes
they're like classic songs.
Yeah.
Now it's like you go to see the Beatles,
you want to hear,
I don't know what to say.
The Beatles,
they're all picking on another,
a better lender.
Scattered a guns and roses.
If you go to see a,
you know,
whatever,
whoever the fuck it is,
you expect to hear the classics.
I.
Yes.
Maybe it's different when you're a guy
from a different era.
He's from a different era than we are
hopeless songs.
Don't have to catch you off guard jokes
too.
That's why jokes don't work forever
because the song you're here and you
become familiar with and you learn the
lyrics,
you know,
and you like it.
You like it more.
You want to hear,
I mean songs.
Repeat them.
Doug Stanhope was a great bit about
that.
Here's a great bit about songs being
fucking lazy.
It's really funny to hear it.
He says like the same punchline over and
over and over again,
and then he just,
I don't want to give away the actual way
sets up the bit,
but it's funny.
That's very funny.
But it's true.
Yeah.
But some,
some guys,
they don't want to let go of that shit.
They don't want to let go of that old
stuff.
No,
they,
they feel like,
well jerry was always said that and I
don't know him,
but I,
I mean,
I don't know why I know him,
but um,
he said like that he thinks that the
people come for the act and not the
performer.
And maybe at one point they did,
they want to see your act.
I think lentil feels that way too.
They come to see the jokes in a way
that's true.
But I also think that once they know
your jokes,
they want new jokes from the personality
they like.
Yeah.
Like,
like Seinfeld did that I'm telling you
for the last time we did a whole hour
special of old jokes.
Yeah.
That he was done with.
But that was like,
those are,
there are,
there were again,
they were 20 year old bits and I don't
think that special was well received.
I asked,
you know,
I don't think I saw it but don't
understand.
I understand why you'd want to do that
if you'll make some money,
but it doesn't feel good to do it.
And he has what I seem to new shit.
It's like he's new stuff kills.
It was doing when he goes out and just
start to work on things like he sees a
fucking really good comment.
He's a great comic.
There's no doubt about it.
But I think his idea is different than
the idea of the current guys and maybe
in a bit he's resisting this new trend
is the trend that everybody does.
Well it's burr or ck.
Are you?
Everybody releases a special and then
abandoned the material.
I do.
It already does it?
Everybody I know does it and there's.
Then there's a few guys that just don't
really specials.
They just don't.
And they have like really old material.
Like I know a few guys that are like
really good comics,
but they just don't put out specials
because they want to keep doing the act.
They just don't want to be.
They don't want to be committed also to
to recording like that.
There's a lot of pressure to bat and
everything down and tightened it up and
then get ready to release it.
Ready,
press,
play,
record go.
You know this a,
a lot of pressure in that.
I love doing it until I'm like,
amy did it weird.
She did.
She did her special and then she toured
until the special aired so now she has
to start over.
But for me I will as soon as it was shot
I wanted it done.
So by the time it airs or some like I
got.
Fuck.
I couldn't wait to not say those things
and couldn't fucking wave.
Yeah.
That shit man.
I just.
One of the finished.
Yeah,
everybody's got their own way of doing
it,
you know.
But I think the point is that in this
day and age,
the public demands content.
Sure,
you'll have to put it out and you're
putting out a lot of content anyway
because you have your radio show,
you have your podcast,
you know,
I remember you used to write a lot of
blogs and you used to,
you're used to be pretty prolific with
blogs.
That was because we were off the radio
and I was blogging a,
all these sex that actually became happy
endings.
The first book,
it was all these blogs I wrote about
things I was doing and I had nowhere I
started writing again,
reach that really want to do another
book on my head,
a sexual experience with this girl.
And uh,
I just had to write after it because it
was,
it was really weird and intimate and
sexy.
And yet what happened?
I just felt connected.
I felt really connected,
no drugs.
And then she,
uh,
no drugs.
And then she texted me from the elevator
and said,
which one is the,
uh,
which one is the lobby?
And I realized what a dope.
I just had the l one that says,
Al,
I,
I am not kidding you.
That she asked which one was the lobby
and she wasn't Jonathan Mistake,
um,
and I had to write,
I had to write it.
I'm like,
it was so because it was,
I'm not good at going back and grabbing
shit.
I'm,
and maybe that's the radio training
where you're just alive.
We,
we're talking,
but I had to do it in the moment.
Just write it like I'm good at writing
then,
but I'm not good at going back and go,
wow.
Two years ago when this happened and
people aspect,
there'll be nothing to show.
I'm like,
I'm not good at going back and writing
all that shit because the emotion for it
is past.
Do you ever try those transcription
software programs where you talk and it
just records what you're saying?
I have another follow up series,
but I do use that a lot when I used to
write for time once in awhile and I
would just talk out the whole fucking
article because I'm not good at starting
up a lot about and all of a sudden I'm
good at organizing and editing,
but I yapped it out already.
I will be running for Time magazine and
David asked me,
they would,
they would ask me to write about the
first article I wrote.
I wish I didn't write actually about
prostitution.
Why do you wish you didn't write it?
Because I.
There's certain things I said it just,
I wished I had said it smarter.
I wish I had been clearer.
I was talking about how John shouldn't
be embarrassed and in a way I agree with
that,
but there was certain things that people
in the sex industry who had been victims
of trafficking and stuff like I should
probably address that better.
Um,
there is a big difference between
trafficking and a woman who just decides
to have sex with guys for money.
And there are a lot of those women and
feminists don't want to admit those
women exist because they still,
for them,
they'll push up the trafficking numbers
because it's a stronger argument against
prostitution.
It's like I get it.
The traffickers should be executed and
saved the people who are being
trafficked.
But if someone makes a decision and they
just want to do it,
well there's one friend of mine who's an
artist and she's a feminist and she's
actually pretty successful and she's
actually talked pretty openly about when
she was younger,
she would do stuff like that where she
would fuck older rich guys for money.
And she's like,
there's nothing wrong with it.
Like I chose to do it.
I did it because it was a great way for
me to pay my bills.
It's easy.
These are guides I chose to have sex
with.
They were nice guys.
I'd fuck them.
I'd take the money and she'd make,
you know,
I don't know,
whatever the pay a thousand bucks,
whatever the fuck it is.
And she could get that in a couple of
hours.
We're rather than working for an entire
week for probably more than we are.
And it's the same group of people that
are saying you shouldn't be ashamed of
sex and keep your laws off my body are
the same ones as saying,
if you're getting paid for what,
you should be ashamed of it and I should
be able to lead.
It's so silly.
It's silly.
It's all silly because first of all,
it should you be ashamed if you massage
people,
if you give him a back rub.
Is that.
Is that a shameful?
No,
that's a very respected thing.
If someone tells you their massage
therapist,
oh,
you're making people feel good,
what do you do?
I just rub dicks and really good at
Robin Dicks and guys like it.
Oh well they.
They probably feel real good,
but now when it comes to pleasure,
we don't allow pleasure in the genital
area that were like,
whoa,
that's the dirty naughty prep.
Why I don't go to like is Asian massage
places don't do that.
No,
we're rushing because they feel like
those to me are more sex slaves.
That's what I don't like.
The energy there.
I,
I've very rarely gone and I've got maybe
two in my life in those places and I
don't go ever go to massage places
because I live an ethical pervert.
I feel like I like to,
and I know that there are certain women
that do it because I've had a couple of
women I dated,
legitimately dated
that wound up doing stuff like that for
money after that they told me about
like,
like really and had never done my
dynamic with them,
so I know for 100 percent fact they
weren't being pimped at forest.
I know they weren't,
but I don't like a massage place where I
think somebody has to do it.
Like it doesn't again,
that's just sad to me.
Like we're rushing place where I think
that they're being brought over for
these reasons,
like talking to a girl and I get
contacted with social media all the time
and if,
if I,
if I've talked to her,
I found out she's rushing and I'm not to
be raised in Russia.
Ngos are hot,
but I start to doubt what the,
uh,
like I talked to one girl off a website
and I wasn't game right away.
And uh,
she got a little weird.
I'm like,
are you being forced to do this?
And she was like,
oh no,
no.
I'll talk to you later.
We just never spoke again,
but like it was just
um,
it
wasn't something she was setting you up.
I don't know.
It's just not a sexy energy.
This is not even sent me up,
but maybe it's just somebody was doing
it so she had to pay back something.
I don't know,
but that's not a sexual energy.
It's a sad energy.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
So you definitely clearly differentiate.
Yeah.
You're unethical pervert.
Nothing wrong with that.
Yeah.
I mean,
you're a good guy.
Yeah.
I just,
I don't like the idea of I,
but I think everybody should look at it
that way.
It's almost like.
But people get married just for money.
Like how many married?
It's like,
what?
Are you just a hooker with one client?
I mean,
is that what you are?
Fuck yeah,
dude.
I met this woman the other day.
She was like 40 years old.
Hot as fuck.
Her husband looks like he's about 70.
He's got terrible.
Posture is leaning over.
He stopped,
stepped out of a fucking bad ass Bentley
or whatever the fuck it was.
Some beautiful car.
And you're like,
oh,
okay,
I see what's going on there.
Yeah,
no worries.
I mean maybe you have the best
personality ever,
but the dude looked like it was just
falling asleep while he's walking.
Yeah.
You know what that's about.
It's a real rich older guy who got some
hot piece of ass who is younger than him
by like at least 30 years and they're
both getting what they want.
She wants a guy who maybe talk to her
nicely and it isn't some young guy
that's fucking acting like an asshole
who can take care of her.
He wants to young,
beautiful like it.
As long as you both honest and
respectful,
who cares?
It is a form of prostitution.
Shirt is.
It is.
Absolutely.
A lot of marriages are form of
prostitution.
People just don't want to admit it
because they think the prostitution is
bad.
Sex for money is bad.
But like there's a lot of people that
are engaged in some sexual relations
with people that are only doing it for
money.
How many women try to me,
let me try to trap basketball players.
Oh yeah.
So your prostate,
if you try to trap a ballplayer and get
pregnant,
you want the money.
That's prostitution.
Well,
it's a payday.
They want a kid.
They want some Dick.
Huh?
I want some cash.
It's a package deal.
Beautiful package deal.
Look,
you can't get a better package to get
knocked up by an NBA guy.
I mean Jesus Christ who wouldn't take a
load for Lebron,
going to ask him to put a bag on you.
Crazy.
If you do a lot of money,
you know,
and,
and there's nothing you can sign where
if you have a kid,
he won't get money.
Can't sign away that kids write to his
money.
As soon as they came out with genetic
testing,
boy that changed the game.
I said,
no one's denying change the game.
You gotta tell me fucking ty cobb didn't
lie about a few of them.
I'm sure you know a ted Williams doesn't
even look like me.
Good point to those guys.
Probably dump loads and the gals all
over the country.
Then.
No Way.
What are you going?
How are you going to find out?
How would you find out who she going to
tell you?
Dude,
I fuck ty cobb and for somebody.
It's a different game,
man.
Babe Ruth.
A lot of fat face,
a little babies running around there
probably are a
little babe ruth legs moving.
It's so funny when you look back at Babe
Ruth at bobby that he had so ridiculous
as fat,
Gut,
fat,
gut and eating hot dogs.
Drinking beer.
Good picture though.
You know,
he had a deauville,
multifaceted player and I love the quote
and Cobb and it ran pretty well for fat
man.
That was the only thing you can say
about Babe Ruth.
Ty cobb is one of the most underrated
films ever by the way,
with fucking Robert Wool and uh,
and Tommy Lee Jones is ty cobb.
Oh,
that's good movie.
Probably secretly fairly accurate.
Yeah.
You know,
you think about it,
a lot of athletes are,
and especially back then was really very
few repercussions for being a piece
shit.
Yeah.
It really wouldn't get out.
And I won't say the quote,
but it's got arguably the best quote in
movie history,
which I'll tell you after you tell me
now.
It's just really vicious,
racist and I just don't want to deal
with anything.
I know the one.
Yeah,
I know you're talking about my favorite
quote ever.
There's no way to squeeze it into
conversation,
but it's a funny a budget.
It's just a funny fucking thing.
It's a funny thing too,
when you think about athletes and how
competitive they have to be in how
ruthless you have to be,
you know?
And then that sort of bleeds out into
the rest of their life,
you know,
and it bleeds out into the way they deal
with a fellow players,
the way they deal with women that deal
with managers or anybody.
I mean there's athletic athletics is a
ruthless,
ruthless pursuit.
It is.
I mean,
it just is.
Have you tasted on?
No.
Oh yeah,
he'd be great.
I would love to.
You had him on your show,
right?
Launch.
Yeah.
And I'm sure he would do this if he was
here.
He would love you.
I'm sure he does.
Love you.
He loves you.
Have.
Say when I first met with,
Yay.
Yeah,
he's,
he's awesome,
but he's a great athlete and just,
he's like kind of the personification.
Everything you can go right and
everything that can go wrong and sort of
balance out at the end.
I mean he sort of achieve homeostasis at
the end of his life or it's at the end
like balance.
I mean he's at 50 years old,
he's got family,
he's got this great new career where
he's does that one man show and it's
hugely successful.
He loves it.
He was a recent article in sports
illustrated.
We was talking about doing that one man
show and how excited he gets to do and
how fun it is.
And he's amazing at it too,
you know?
And then that documentary sort of
revived him and then the one man show
came behind that.
So he's like in this new stage in his
life where he's achieved this strange
new balance,
you know,
like foremen,
they always say foreman in when we were
kings,
it might have been a norman mailer who
said he was this.
He was,
he was not a likable guy and he's.
Then he gets knocked out,
he comes back and he's a lovable grill
salesman.
Funny Dude,
one of my favorite clips ever,
just him on the tonight show.
There's a clip of him talking to Johnny
Carson in 1990 before he fought
Alex Stewart and take a minute and a
half.
It's just a funny like what a lovable
fun guy.
He was a different guy when he came back
for sure.
He became a preacher,
ballooned up to well over 300 pounds.
And what's really interesting is he made
his comeback,
I want to say he was 36 years old and
everybody thought it was a joke.
He was hugely fat,
like way,
way,
way overweight when he made his first
comeback fight.
And I remember as a boxing fan I was
like,
wow,
it's kind of sad.
Look on them.
And then slowly but surely over time his
body trimmed down and he got more muscle
and less fat.
And then he knocked Gerry Cooney the
fuck out.
And when he did that,
everybody went,
whoa.
He is for real.
Like this is crazy.
Like George Foreman,
not only is he for real,
he might be a better fighter than he was
when he was young and he fought.
I remember when he fought Evander
Holyfield and he lost.
I think he lost a decision.
Yeah,
you did it correctly.
I did and I love at the end he said
something about this is for people over
40 hip,
hip,
hooray.
That was such a great quote by will have
enough to lose the like what a victory
it was for,
for age.
You know,
there's really knocked out Michael
Moore,
I want to say he was 46 years old and
Michael Maura was beating him and
winning and he hit him with a straight
right hand on the Chin and more just
flattened.
It was crazy.
It was.
I think he was the oldest guy to ever
gained the heavyweight title at the
time.
Or do you feel the time?
What did he beat them for?
The title?
Think you'd beat Michael Moore for the
title.
He lost it.
The holyfield.
Is that what?
I don't remember him.
I think slept.
Having to pitch one more time.
One more time.
We'll wrap this thing up when you come
back.
I think what?
Find out how old George Foreman was when
he won the heavyweight title,
and here's the thing.
I don't think they had human growth or
if they did have human growth hormone.
It wasn't really being used by boxers.
I don't think they used to get human
growth hormone from the pituitary glands
of dead people.
He was 45,
45 when he won the title.
It'll be 26 year old Michael Moore.
Michael Moore was only 26 at the time.
Michael Moore was a murderer,
light heavyweight.
He was like one of the best light
heavyweights ever.
But light heavyweight was too hard for
him to make.
So we went up to heavyweight and uh,
that was when he won the title and then
who did he lose it,
lose it to Holyfield plus to Tommy,
Tommy Morrison to last a decision at
Tommy Marston was like Tommy Marson's
big biggest victory ever.
And that was like post a morrison was
lost,
was just before he beat Michael Moore.
Really interesting.
Unless Shannon Briggs,
he lost a decision to Shannon Briggs.
Shannon,
the cannon,
let's go champ.
Um,
and then I feel like the before to the
Shannon fight.
Oh,
it was before it as well.
Well,
it failed.
Last is 91.
Morrison was what is the,
what's the order of his fights?
So he had the holyfield loss,
the morrison loss,
and then right afterwards he got shot at
the title.
What it says.
That's crazy.
Why would they give them a shot at the
title right away to Los Angeles for the
vacant Wbo heavyweight title.
Then he won the WBA Ibf and lineal
heavyweight titles.
When he beat Michael Moore a,
beat him for the WBO title.
He lost that decision.
A lot of people thought that he should
have won the Shannon Briggs fight,
I believe.
Was the Shannon breaks fighter?
Was it the Morrison fight?
I'd have to go back and look at it
again.
I think maybe both of them were
controversial,
but uh,
the Morrison or the more fun as is
undisputed decision.
And a briggs was a mixed md.
Does that make decision or what does
that majority decision?
That was briggs.
Yeah,
the breaks fight was the one,
I think that was controversial when
shannon braDy against George Foreman.
We're just going over the George Foreman
career.
Let's wrap this up.
Yeah,
this was fun,
dude.
I always enjoy.
What are you.
I haven't asked you one prediction
because I,
Anthony Johnson against,
uh,
against columbia.
Uh,
I do not have a prediction.
I never predict,
but I think that if it goes into the
third,
fourth and fifth rounds,
it's gonna be really hard for rumbled a
win.
Right?
I think rumbles chances of winning the
fight come early.
He's a,
he's a goddamn short term hurricane that
rips the house right out of the
foundation.
He's not necessarily a long,
long storm.
I think what rumbled does is comes at
you fast and hard and he can go fast and
hard rather than anybody.
It's just really hard for him to go with
that style.
More than three rounds.
The only time we've ever seen them do it
three rounds.
He beat phil davis,
beat the shit out of them for three
rounds.
But phil davis wasn't threatening him.
It was a.
He was fighting at his pace.
He was completely in control of that
fight and you want a clear cut,
unanimous decision,
hurt davis a bunch of times,
and it was super dangerous.
Also,
I feel like rumble johnson today scarier
than the rumble johnson,
the flat phil davis,
but rumble when he fought dc the first
time when he fought cormier the first
time he was preparing for jon jones,
so he's preparing for a different fight.
The fight was a last minute replacement
with cormier and cormier's.
Just a out wrestled them.
I mean daniel is one of the best
wrestlers in the sport.
Period out.
Wrestled them and then eventually got
his back and choked him.
I just think that it's a terrifying
fight for cormay because this fucking
guy hits so god hard.
He's fun.
If you make any mistakes and mistakes,
he lands a fucking nuclear bomb on your
face.
Be able to scare them.
Scare fighters.
The way that rumble does.
He has that.
He think that old school of afraid of
being beaten up in the school yard,
like when it could be beat Michael
Johnson the way you had it on the
ground.
That's how I would get beaten up,
like that was so claustrophobic for me
to watch that,
to like not be able to pull your arm.
Like that was a really uncomfortable
fight because it just can't.
I can't fight.
So yeah,
I wanted it stopped.
I wanted to stop before they stopped it.
It was bothering me.
I was like,
this guy's not going to win.
This fight is getting the fuck beat out
of him.
He's getting his head punched and he's
one of the best fighters in the world
and you're ruining them,
but he's just taking this beating.
Like just stop the god damn fight.
He was so outmatched,
but he did hurt habib early in the
fight.
He heard he hurt khabib in the first
round,
but then the fucking khabib not being
able to make the weight against tony
ferguson.
I'm just like this god damn weight
cutting god.
It's such a horrible,
horrible practice.
It makes me sick.
That was heartbreaking because everybody
wants that fight and now they say
they're going to be scared to put him
against conor.
I mean they're going to have that pair
of fucking main event.
You can't,
you can't,
and by the way,
one of the things that we've talked
about it on the fight companion podcast
we did the other day,
we pulled up the uh,
luke rockhold quote,
luke rockhold is his training partner
and he was saying that he couldn't get
blood to his liver and that was
something was going on.
He was in deep pain.
He wasn't getting blood to his liver.
I'm like,
yeah,
you fucking kidding me.
Like this guy and this guy is going to
do that again.
He's going to lose that weight again
after that.
And apparently he said that he had the
same problem in the Michael Johnson
fight,
the Michael Johnson fight.
He wound up getting down to 1:55,
but he was having the same issue where
it wasn't getting blood to his liver.
Like,
what the fuck,
man,
you know,
and george st pierre is did an interview
today where he's saying that it's going
to kill one of us.
Like one of us is gonna die from weight
cutting.
Lindsey's going to middleweight now.
Right.
I think that's one of the reasons why
it's better.
Yeah,
I think it's better.
I mean look out,
god damned good.
Calvin gasoline looked against or
faster.
Johny hendricks I thought looked good
too.
Yeah,
he looked great.
It looked great against hector lombard
getting heavy.
I makes you faster,
but I guess it's just not draining
yourself.
That's all it is because he's not
getting heavier.
He was always heavy.
He but he would be the same weight and
then dehydrate himself down to one 70
and then go back up to [inaudible] 90
somewhere around that,
which is what probably with johny
hendricks was instead this time just
last a couple of pounds.
Made one 85 easy and then look fucking
great against hector lombard.
I would like to see more guys do that
because I think that's so much
healthier.
So much and the performances are better.
Look at donald cerrone.
Donald's ronnie since going up to
welterweight looks far better than they
looked at lightweight.
Yeah.
I always wonder why they do that and
I've asked them before and they just
say,
look,
you're going to be fighting a heavier
guy.
I like,
why don't you just fight it?
Your normal kind of your weighT,
your walk around now,
wouldn't it be better and not have to
cut all that weight and put it back on?
It just seems crazy.
Honestly.
In their defense,
I think there should be more weight
classes.
I think there should be a weight class
every 10 pounds.
I think if there was a waY class every
10 pounds,
it would alleviate a lot of the extreme
cutting.
You'd have a 1:45,
1:55,
one 65 slash 75,
85,
95 and then go up like that.
I think if we did that,
we'd have more champions.
It would be more exciting.
I think it would be an excellent way to
have a champion versus champion fights
because he wouldn't be that much much
closer.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
That would be interesting to watch.
Maybe that maybe they'll do it.
I mean,
I hope so.
Sixty five versus 75 pound champ.
Fifty five versus 65.
There's a lot of fights you can make
when you have these big ass super
fights.
That one guy could go up a little down a
little.
It's not a giant,
a giant jump.
Yeah.
I felt bad for tony ferguson and it just
sucks.
It does suck.
You're going to come up to the buffalo
fight.
Um,
I don't know if I'm working for,
uh,
for uh,
courtenay johnson and buffalo,
right?
Yeah.
If I can,
I will.
I usually go to vegas,
but that's what I want to see is that is
a,
is a yoga every guest that to 11
years to 11.
I think this is a,
it's a win against
weidman versus saucy is a great fight.
oliveira is another one.
He went up to 1:55.
He's fighting well brooks now I liked
that.
Um,
yeah,
that's all.
Vera has been.
Just struggling to stay at 1:45.
Just brutal breaks you down man.
It's just so bad for you.
Yeah.
He didn't even miSs a thursday over.
He.
Um,
no.
He beat pedis.
Pedis didn't make the weight and he beat
pettis.
No,
that was max holloway.
Max holloway beat pettis.
He lost to pedes pedes guillotined him.
Uh,
But I think he's had a couple losses in
a row.
Who the fuck was posing as last loss he
wasn't met at recently?
Who criticized his weight that I think
it made me nothing going to.
He was,
they're pissed off that somebody had
said something disrespectful.
That is.
Wait.
Oh,
he lost to ricardo.
Lamas.
You got.
He got submitted by ricardo lamas.
So it was a great fight for llamas.
And then before that pet submitted them.
And then before that he beat miles.
Jury.
He's just,
um,
I think it's just,
it's another one of those Guys just,
he's a really talented guy,
but that fucking weight cut is just
horrible.
It's the worst part of the sport.
There should be a way to do it,
to eliminate it.
I think they should be weighing these
guys in every Fifteen days or something
like that and finding out what they
really way.
And I think it's crazy.
I really do.
I think it's insane to dehydrate your
brain,
your body,
get to death's door than 24 hours later
have a cage fight.
Gsp said there,
he said I didn't.
I didn't know they did that in boxing
and he was saying about inboxing a month
out.
They waste,
you can't lose like 20 percent of your
whatever the percentage of body.
I never considered that,
but that Would probably be a good way to
do it.
Maybe they will.
There's the guy who runs the California
state athletic commission.
His name is andy foster and he's
probably,
in my opinion,
one of the very best commissioners in in
mma today in athletic commission
commissioners because he's just really
proactive.
I believe he's had some mma fights
himself and he's,
he's an accomplished martial artists.
He really understands the sport and
they're doing.
They're taking some really proactive
approaches to cutting weight,
cutting and making sure that people
don't dehydrate themselves as much.
And he,
he was really proactive and for
performance enhancinG drugs,
catching people doing drugs beFore.
The usada thing with the ufc came along
too,
so just need better regulations,
more people on top of things.
This is how bad I want to lose my gut.
I felt like I do exercise if I actually,
uh,
I think I asked,
it was either wonderful or his father,
what the pace was that they put on and a
part of me actually considered putting
the paste on and just sitting in the
fucking in abilene to thank you.
I didn't know what to sweat.
Yeah.
But he's Like,
you don't want it.
That's 30.
You'll lose the wrong way.
No,
you'll just get dehydrated.
That's not going to lose body fat.
You just got to stop eating sugar.
Do you sugar?
Very rarely,
but occasionally I'm doing,
I go the only fucking two periods.
You know what I mean?
Like I want to misbehave and I'll just
shove bad food.
My fat face.
Hard not to tasty.
Tasty.
I love a good treat.
I love a good ice cream sundae.
I have a hard time.
Damn it,
dude.
I love it.
Woo.
Frozen yogurt.
Oh my fucking manager.
And what a couple of.
We looked like prancing
on santa monica boulevard to the Yogurt
stop.
Fuck it.
Three times a week.
We can't stop eating this cheese.
It's the fucking best.
They have the sugar free chocolate.
Holy shit.
Is that to get all those toppings?
I do.
I'm reese's pieces crazy.
I'll maybe a little bit of coconut
shavings,
but lately I've done more.
I rarely do.
I rarely do it,
but when I do it I go hard.
I go to cold stone creamery and get a
fucking giant sub with like peanut
butter and hot fudge and reese's pieces
and chocolate ice cream and whipped
cream on it and god dammit doesn't that.
Doesn't that fuck you.
I felt like my throat,
my throat clearing idiot and that type
of stuff fucks me up like lactose.
I can't take coffee.
I think mess in my throat up.
Last time I throw it,
I stoppeD drinking butter,
coffee on the show because I would drink
it and I would be constantly coughing.
It's just when you're talking for long
periods of time like this,
you occasionally going to have to clear
your throat like that.
Yeah.
But I mean like when I,
when I think about it more,
I have to do it more,
but I mean when uh,
when I'm like,
lactose fucking kills me.
Ice cream,
frozen yogurt,
yogurt too.
There's so much.
When you have an ice cream sundae mean
you're getting.
Who knows how many hundreds of grams of
sugar,
but it feels so good.
Well,
it's going in and then you just.
Then you regret it.
yeah.
Your body feels like dog shit for a long
time.
For an hour or so afterWards.
I feel like dog shit.
I feel I feel that way for a few days.
Like I gotta I gotta eat good for a
while,
go to the gym and then when I started
this I've never had an attitude.
I never will,
but I want to have abs.
You're not far away from amps.
I don't know.
When you have a real trainer,
like a really good trainer.
That fucking kicks your ass.
You got to check that.
You go to three different ones.
Three different ones.
One,
uh,
yeah.
Well one couldn't do another schedule so
I use another one.
One monday,
one friday and they want to use tuesday,
thursday.
So I'll schedule.
So every time you work out you workout
with a trainer.
Every time.
Unless I'm here and I'll do a little
something,
I'll pop up on the old elliptical for 20
minutes.
We all drove through a few things that
I've remembered do 45 minutes by myself,
but I would say almost every time I use
a trainer because I don't like.
I'm fucking lazy.
I'm lazy.
I like to be fucking lazy.
They will at least make you do different
shit squad,
you know,
like all these full body exercises I'm
doing things I wouldn't do on my own.
It's interesting that you say you're
lazy,
but you work out four days a week.
That's not lazy.
I do that in spite of my laziness.
Like I am lazy.
You do stand up seven nights a week,
but you're lAzy.
You do your radio show how many days a
week,
five days a week,
but you're lazy.
You do your podcast on top of the radio
show two days a week,
but you're lazy.
Yeah.
It's weird I think,
but I.
Maybe I,
maybe I,
maybe.
Maybe I'm not.
I always feel like I'm a lazy bum and I
really do.
I feel like I'm a fucking hard and I'm
doing all this stuff in spite of being
lazy,
like I'm fighting laziness constantly.
Maybe it's the way you're defining maybe
your self defining yourself in a very
negative and limiting way.
Maybe by thinking that like you're lazy.
Even though the evidence points to the
contrary,
you're still doing all these things.
A lazy person would find a way to not
work out.
A lazy person would find a way to fuck
off and call in sick
to the radio show a point.
Yeah.
I don't think you're lazy.
I think your self critical,
which is usually what a lot of artists
are,
you know,
a lot of artists hate everything they do
and they Just,
you know,
they're constantly trying to do the best
and it just never good enough and they
get pissed,
you know?
So it might be like this way you're
looking at things,
you might have to blank that out and
just not think like that.
Just not allow those thoughts to get
into your head.
Like if I wanted to fuck off and not
work out,
I'm sure I could come up with some sort
of a reason,
but I don't,
I don't consider myself lazy in that
regard.
I'm just not a workout too much.
It would be ridiculous if I said I was
lazy.
I make myself do it with a trainer that
also forCes you to do it.
But I made myself do it too.
Like it's,
there's no,
not much difference between you and me
in that regard.
I'll give myself a few days like,
well,
I'm still busy doing press this week.
I would give myself,
like I did it twice,
but uh,
I'll let the third day go.
Like I'm not as driven as I was at one
point,
bUt the trainers,
I always show up.
I never don't show up.
I don't cut.
The workouts are like,
you just make yourself dillard.
It sounds like baking shall be faithful.
Like,
you know,
once I start cheating,
goodbye.
That's all shades are open.
Floodgates are open because I'm no
longer perfect.
Cd shit comes in.
I'm not perfect.
I think that's what you're doing.
I think you're defining.
I think it's a negative definition that
you've latched onto yourself,
that you're lazy because it's impossible
for you to be lazy when you look at all
the things you do.
That's a good point.
I hadn't thought of it that way.
Yeah.
I've always identified myself like that.
Maybe I'm just a driven guy who's tired.
Yeah,
that sounds like.
I mean,
jesus christ.
Think about all the shit you're doing.
You're doIng five days of radio.
You're doing two days a podcast.
You're doing standup every night.
You're working at night and then you're
getting up in the morning to do radio.
What?
Seven?
What time be there from eight to 11.
Eight to 11.
So you're getting up at seven?
Yeah,
that's fucking early for a comic.
doing a set at night.
Like what time is your set?
I usually stl giving the early ones when
I requested it,
so I'm usually done by about 8:30.
I'd be home by nine.
A little something to yell some
vietnamese food and relax.
Yeah,
but still,
even then like you're barely getting
eight hours sleep then if you go right
to bed.
I never get a dollar,
so that's what I'm saying.
can you maybe you need.
Everybody needs eight hours.
I like eight.
I got eight hours last night.
So you feel refreshed when you wake up.
You feel great to feel refreshed.
I feel amazing.
I feel fantastic.
It was to get that eight hours.
I just think that that's one of those
things is non negotiable.
I just think that.
I mean there's gonna be days where I
can't I gotta get up early for a flight
or whatever.
Yeah.
But I think sleep is one of the most non
negotiable things.
Sleeping and drinking water and eating
healthy food,
those are pretty non negotiable with.
Have you heard of?
It depends.
Last nIght it was pretty late.
Last night was probably like 1:00 in the
morning.
I got up at a like somewhere around nine
ish.
That's still.
That's still a good schedule for a
comedian,
for comedians.
Great.
Well it's good that the store's not far
away.
I couldn't get to the store and a half
an hour at night,
get there and do a set.
I'm done by 11,
1130.
I'm home by one,
you know,
whatever.
That's what scared me though.
It
was the idea of doing radio during the
day and then like I did afternoons I do,
I set at night and then one and then
you.
Then you're naughty.
That's what you're wearing and.
And nobody's around.
Nobody is around.
But you,
you,
you're really texting the dregs at 4:00
AM right here.
Yeah.
You bet.
Choy,
your best options.
I've gone to bed.
You don't have the best,
best opposite.
Taken all the loads.
They can handle it or they have.
They've given them.
she's really good girl.
Alright.
Jim norton.
You new special is on netflix.
Mouthful of shame.
Yeah,
it's on a as of today.
There it is.
bam.
Well you look great in that picture.
Oh shit dude.
There's a snow storm.
I actually just pulled that.
I actually just screen cap that because
I didn't like the pixel using.
Sorry.
I just screamed and especially could you
guys use that?
And I'm like,
okay,
perfect.
Yeah,
that is,
it's.
I liked that too because you're in the
middle of a set,
you know,
like that's a real picture.
That's a real like you're not posing
like I posed for a bunch of netflix
pictures,
pictures and I was like,
well there's one they took of me where
my hands over my mouth,
but it's a screen grab from the set.
I'm doing a joke right?
Cover my mouth,
but I'm like,
I don't want to use that a because you
can't see my face and be.
Because I know it's a mouthful of shame,
but it seems like I'm going,
oh,
I said something naughty,
which is not what the joke is,
but it looks like I called it mouthful
of shame and that went,
oh,
look out folks.
It's fucking awful.
Yeah,
that could be a pRoblem if somebody was
centered,
cynical and they were like,
who's this guy the fuck out of here with
your mouth full to say whatever I want.
No one,
no one sensory me.
Isn't netflix amazing in that regard?
I could not be happier.
So,
so amazing.
So good.
Robby process.
It wasn't.
It's an hour in one minute or hour and
two minutes.
It was an hour and 14 with a set.
I chopped the bid up and I asked robbie,
we,
you might want to turn this a bit,
but it's up to you and like this one
part and he was right.
The trim was actually smart and that
was,
that was the whole suggestion.
Yeah,
there was.
The only notes they gave me when I was
recording was like,
one of the ladies really enjoyed the
dolphin bit.
She's like,
you didn't do the dolphin bed on that
side.
Oh,
it's just because I did.
Don't worry,
it'll be on.
I go,
I just didn't want to do it during that
sec.
So it was,
I don't want to do.
I didn't want any of the sets to be
longer than an hour and some of them are
going to have material that's not in the
other ones that will decide which way to
do it,
but that was it.
Like I like a bit.
Yeah,
you're good.
Don't worry.
That bit's going to be in there.
Yeah.
So that's a nice note to get.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's,
I think the best venue right now for
standup by far.
I don't think there's anything even
close to netflix.
It's everywhere now,
like didn't get released everywhere,
so I'll go out and do gigs,
hopefully in the next couple of months,
start booking a bunch of shit and
someone can listen to this podcast right
now,
hanging up it close,
close the podcast and then go right to
their tv and instantaneously watch it.
It's stats tHe best on their phone.
Yeah,
I opened it on my phone before.
It's weird.
It's amazing.
Like you're watching it on like even
like did they don't care about the
premiere,
like they care,
but like I had a bunch of stuff like
that,
but I never actually said,
you know,
don't kill yourself.
It's going to be a second wave.
You know how much press I did.
I did,
I did like I maybe I called a couple of
evil.
I don't remember.
It was,
it was nothing.
No,
it was nothing like I had to do for
comedy central comedy central involved
like there's like a bunch of
obligations.
If you do an hbo special,
I would imagine probably be the same
thing.
Same thing,
same for epics and again,
just because they have a premiere date,
they get numbers.
Yeah,
flakes.
They don't care.
They just want to know that people are
watching it and they can tell and I
don't tell any of us how many people are
watching us get numbers.
They.
Yeah,
they don't tell you shit.
They just go.
We're very,
very happy.
I want to do another one.
Yeah.
I should act like I'm holding out when
you want to do it on and I'm not ready
to happen.
I mean I would make in a year or
something more on the.
I would love to do it.
Then what's your schedule do you like to
do?
Do you like to do one a year?
It's not always possible,
but at my age my goal is to do one every
year,
year and a half maximum because by then
a lot of the material is like when I
touch topical stuff now I try to touch
it in a way that ties into an overall
theme so it still makes sense.
Like I talk about how I don't really
think I'm a pervert and I mentioned that
jared is a pervert,
but I don't do a whole long.
Jarrod said I'd like to have something
that is fairly timeless to that bit.
Nothing specific to the moment where
you're like,
wait,
I don't remember that.
You know what he did so that I.
Yeah,
but after a year and a half I just lose
interest in what I'm saying,
joke wise and that plus I liked doing
that.
YeaH,
I love doing that.
I feel like why not just put it out?
There's so many places to put specials
out.
Right?
And especially when you're doing so much
standup.
If you're doing standup six,
seven nights a week and then you're
constantly doing a radio show,
there's constantly new themes running
through your head.
You want to get that out there and it's
always there and it's like I may
actually do shorter videos or something.
I don't know how to get them out.
Like things that are so topical just to
just to spit them out there.
So they're there and they're posted
getting wasted in a set.
I want to be your self esteem coach.
I'm going to pump you up.
No more negative thinking,
positive gym,
but then again you might be fueled by
that negative thing and it might be why
you're so prolific.
It's a combination of both.
Like I could feel good and be funny too,
but I didn't even realize it was a
negative thought.
I just think I was confusing being tired
with being lazy and I think that's a
good.
You just pointed something out that
makes a lot of stuff.
DefInitely not lazy.
You got a lot of shit done.
Yeah,
I feel but I.
But I'll watch you and I see you.
You got a company you've got 30 during
the and I'm like motherfucker,
I'm sitting in,
I'm sitting on a block of ice doing
nothing.
what lilly's doing this area here.
You see all your friends comparing.
So no,
I know,
but if you feel lazy when you see your
friends doing these great things.
All the things that I'm doing though,
I really enjoyed doing those things so
they don't seem like work to me.
Like not.
There's not a goddamn thing I do that
seems like work,
whether it's working for the ufc,
whether it's students stand up,
there's obligations.
She'll have to be there to certain time.
There's writing involved.
There's things that I have to do where I
have to sit down and be alone and forced
myself to do that kind of work,
but it doesn't.
None of it seems like work.
It's all fun stuff.
Well,
if I was only doing stuff I want,
believe me,
I wish if somehow watching chatter bait
would advance me in this business,
you'd be fucking.
he'd be seeing my fucking heels and
probably if you did like live commentary
on twitch for chatter bait,
like you have chattery windows in the
background and you're.
You're just sitting there like old old
jesus.
You're not allowed to,
but I do.
What I do want to do is I want to get a
beautiful girl and chatter bait and then
I want to just come on as fucking chip
and sit next to her.
all these years,
jerking off in Portugal
has a great idea.
I want to do that.
Have the look and everything.
I really wanted,
but I would have to have somebody like
somehow capturing,
because you have to be careful.
You don't show them that you'll get
sued.
Like yeah,
there's a way to capture what they've
said and change it a little and put it
out.
I think it's so funny.
Oh,
you have to do it in conjunction with
that girl like you and the girl would
have to have.
The girl would be.
Would he be he be in the room with her
but she wouldn't be.
I can't do anything with porn,
but the girl will be like a sexy girl,
like showing her tits,
like really hot.
You can't do anythIng with foreign
because a serious no,
no.
Just because it was a committee.
I don't want to.
I don't want to cross a certain line.
Like I don't wanna I don't want to be
there while people.
I'm actually fucking right.
I'm not at a judgment,
but I just don't understand what you're
saying,
but I want to.
I want to have fucking chip come on and
just sit there and fucking spoil the
vines.
Fucking talk to show a fucking cooler.
People would be so fucking angry.
People like me wouldn't know you would
enjoy it,
but like could have like you put it in a
couple is so fun.
You wait.
I'm going to fuck the shit out of her
and a feel fucking seconds.
Great idea.
Yeah.
There was like a bib on mashed potatoes.
Where do you see how good I fucking it
and occluder
people would hate it.
Sounds like a plan.
Thank you man.
I appreciate it.
I love this podcast.
I love you man.
You're funny motherfucker.
Is this real silver versus gas tulum
in rio?
Oh my goodness.
Goodness.
Whoa.
Calvin gaslamp's.
He's trying to be the legend.
Killer.
Yeah.
Asking you shall receive.
Who's?
Who is tweeted that.
Oh wow.
Well,
calvin asked for that fight and anderson
apparently said yes.
That is a dangerous fight for anderson
silva.
Kelvin gasoline was a fucking destroys.
He is and they understand against our
parents and I thought was a very
interesting decision.
I didn't agree with it,
but other people did.
They said it wasn't a bad decision.
It wasn't.
It was a close fight.
He didn't get a lot done,
but I felt like I'd have to go over it
and really score it,
but I didn't think it was agregious,
but I do think that anderson is
definitely lost a step and he can get
hit and calvin is a Motherfucker man.
He's a motherfucker.
Wow.
In rio though.
He's going to fight anderson in rio.
the vibe in rio,
but he just fucked up.
Vitorin.
Fortaleza.
He knocked him the fuck out.
Yeah.
Jesus.
He doesn't seem to care where he is.
Him got islam is a beast.
He's a beast.
He's a kid on the way up.
He's only 25.
Two,
right?
How was that young?
I believe.
oh my god.
I believe he's 25.
I believe he won the ultimate fighter.
It's like one of the youngest guys ever
to win it.
Yeah.
Did he all.
It was right?
Yeah,
I remember watching him.
Nobody thought it was gonna win shit.
Now he's way ahead of you.
Right?
I love you too.
He's a beast.
He's another one.
Really good fighter.
He really interesting guy to.
Alright.
Mouthful of shame on netflix starting
today,
a ufc unfiltered and,
uh,
your show matt serra at the great.
Matt that,
terra sarah and me and sam every
morning.
Unserious.
Thank you brother.
Thank you joe.
Bye everybody.
We'll be back tomorrow with someone
fucking good.
Who knows?
Tomorrow.
Hold on.
I'm sorry.
Give me one second.
Oh,
tj kirk,
the amazing atheist.
That'll be fun.
He's great.